Hallo, hier ist MobileMax, Ausgabe Nummer 36 mit pfeffriger, ausgeschlafener Begrüßung. Dennis ist Mittag.
Hallo.
Endlich treffen wir uns nicht mitten in der Nacht und ich bin nicht total im Eimer und das ist ganz großartig. Ich bin allerdings bei meinen Mitdiskutanten nicht ganz so sicher. Dennis, wie sieht's aus?
Voll fit.
Du bist voll fit. Dennis mumpelt gerade an einem Softcake herum. Und ist das dein Telefon? Ja, ist das schon im Airplane-Modus? Meinst du, das ist noch nicht im Airplane-Modus? Moment, Moment, Moment. Deins ist nicht im Airplane-Modus. Bist du denn im GSM? Oder bist du im UMTS? Du bist bestimmt im GSM. Hier gibt's nämlich kein UMTS. Ja, liebe Grüße von einem Mobamex-Führer aus Bamberg. Michael hat uns irgendwie ein schickes Paket mit ganz viel Schoki gemacht. Das hat natürlich den negativen Auswirkungen, dass jetzt hier wieder geschmatzt wird.
Und wir können einfach sagen, Michael ist schuld.
Dass wir noch dicker werden. Genau, so sieht's nämlich aus, aber jetzt will ich auch...
Vielen Dank, nach Bamberg.
Na, vielen Dank. Das habt ihr jetzt davon. Ja, wir blicken auf eine themenreiche Runde, denke ich mal, aber als solche sollten wir diese Runde nämlich vorstellen, denn es gibt einen Neuling, einen Gast, einen Dazukommer, einen... jemand, der noch nicht da war.
Aber erstmal fangen wir vielleicht an mit Dennis. Hallo, Dennis.
Hallo.
Begrüßungsrunde, ich dachte, das ist cool.
Ich bin links, nehme ich an, wie immer.
Du bist links, ja, ja, du bist links.
Max, du bist rechts. Hallo, ich bin Max.
Du bist rechts außen. Ha. Und in der Mitte, zwischen Dennis und Max, begrüße ich Huckel. Hallo, Huckel.
Deswegen machen wir die Sendung jetzt hier am Wochenende, weil in der Woche muss der kleine Huckel ja zur Schule.
Ja, genau.
Und der große Dennis muss auf Maloche.
Auf dem Bau.
Auf dem Bau. Zement schleppen. Wie es deine Art ist. Wobei, bei dir steht jetzt auch Produktrelease irgendwie an, ne?
Ich darf nichts sagen.
Du darfst nichts sagen. Echt?
Ich hab bei Bits und so schon reingehört und die haben ja auch über dieses Gerät gesprochen, diese mysteriöse Texta-Firma von so einem Berliner Start-up.
Und hat alles gestimmt oder war das falsch?
Die wussten glaub ich auch nichts. Meinen aber, sie kennen auch wen. Ich dachte schon mal nicht, ich kenn die ja gar. Ich muss irgendwie anders sein, weil sie ein Testgerät haben wollen und so. Aber alle wollen Testgeräte haben. Alle wollen Testgeräte haben. Da ich mal überlegt, dass es ja hier bestimmt auch zum Thema wird und ich aber gar nicht sagen kann, weil ich nämlich gar nicht weiß, was ist jetzt offiziell und was nicht.
Bring uns mal ein paar Testgeräte mit.
Siehst du, da ist schon ein nächstes Testgerät.
Textgeräte.
Ich glaube, es gibt mehr Leute, die Testgeräte haben wollen als...
Textgeräte....
als die denken, dass sie verkaufen können.
Hab ich jetzt schon zu viel gesagt? Ich hab schon Leute gehört, die wollen sich gleich einen kaufen. Das sind auch die Leute, die zu viel Geld haben und sich sowieso jeden Scheiß kaufen, der mit Strom betrieben wird.
Was willst du denn damit sagen?
Gar nichts. Also generell kann ich sagen, ich bin skeptisch, was E-Books betrifft. Generell, ich glaube nicht an die Durchhaltekraft dieses Marktes. Ich glaube, dass die Mobile Devices insgesamt so sehr von Energieersparnis profitieren werden, dass einfach so was wie ein iPhone, so was wie Buchlesen einfach mal nebenbei macht. Dieses ganze Tintenumdreh, Display-Kram.
Du weißt, dass das gar kein Strom braucht für das Display, wenn nichts geändert wird. Du kannst ja stundenlang die gleichen Seiten zeigen und...
Ja, aber die Leute wollen eben nicht stundenlang die gleichen Seiten. Die wollen im Web surfen, die wollen chatten, die sind einfach connected, die sind das auch gewohnt.
Ja, aber nicht Leute, die Bücher lesen wollen.
Ja, das ist halt genau der Punkt, wo es sich entscheidet, wo ich es auch selber nicht so einschätzen kann. Aber ich glaube, die Leute, die wirklich Bücher lesen wollen, die lesen Bücher. In der Regel. Die hängen dann auch so an ihrem Medium, dass sie nicht bereit sind, sich jetzt auf so ein Device niederzuknien, was ihnen eigentlich nur Einschränkungen bietet. Abgesehen von weniger Rumschleppen.
Aber weniger Rumschleppen ist schon ein Buch.
Aber die haben dann eh mal ein Buch dabei. Jeder, den ich kenne, der ein Buch liest, hat genau ein Buch dabei. Das ist ein Taschenbuch. Das passt dann irgendwie.
Na klar, aber mehr kann er auch nicht mit hinschleppen.
Ich nehm zum Beispiel deine PDFs auf dem Bildschirm unterwegs.
Welchen Bildschirm?
Na, hier Notebook.
Wir müssen sagen, hochgehalten 17 Zoller.
Ich hab zum Beispiel gar kein Buchbücher, um herzuschleppen. Von daher, wenn ich unterwegs bin und ein Buch lesen will, nehm ich dann das PDF, das E-Book sozusagen, und so viel unterwegs, so im Rucksack, dann wiegt ja auch nichts und so, wenn man das immer dabei hat und da seine ganzen Bücher auch mit drauf hat.
Also ich hab hier so einen Text da kleint, ne?
Könnte man so einmal im Monat vielleicht auch mal reingucken.
Na ja, das Mysterium werden wir nicht lösen können. Wann ist da die offizielle Release angekündigt? Was ist da angekündigt offiziell als Release?
Dezember.
Okay, da haben wir noch Plenty of Time. 2009, muss man dazu sagen, ja. Muss man dazu sagen. So, jetzt haben wir verschiedene Experimente gestartet, abgesehen davon, dass ich immer noch rätselte, ob es sinnvoll sein wird, dieser Sendung hier Kapitelmarken zuzuführen. Also wir werden auf jeden Fall mal von dieser Sendung eine mit Kapitelmarken veröffentlichen, je nachdem, was dabei rauskommt. Ob wir die jetzt in den Podcast werfen oder als separaten Download anbieten, das sei jetzt nochmal dahingestellt. Ich weiß, ich hatte ja im Blog gefragt, was ihr da so drüber denkt. Im Kern lässt sich das, glaube ich, zusammenfassen mit die große Mehrheit findet das einen sich toll. Es gibt dann aber so eine kleine fragile Mehrheit, die würde auch von MP3 profitieren. Das Argument, dass man natürlich niemanden unnötigerweise zurücklassen sollte, der jetzt keine andere Möglichkeit hat. Okay, das mag ja greifen. Wesentlichen sind es eigentlich nur noch so uralt Supermarkt-MP3-Player, die kein AAC können und so entsprechende von der deutschen Automobilindustrie designte Autoradios, die aber auch bei MP3 so schlecht sind, dass man noch nicht mal davon sprechen kann, dass sie MP3 abspielen können. Na gut, man muss ja auch irgendwie auf seine Hörer hören und das Ganze soll jetzt auch erstmal ein Experiment sein. Der Grund, warum ich damit jetzt überhaupt angefangen habe, ist, dass ich nun endlich nach ewiger Zeit ein Tool gefunden habe, was es leicht macht, in MP4-Dateien Kapitelmarken einzuführen. Und da bin ich von Thorsten von Bits und so darauf hingewiesen worden, der da sowieso ganz umtriebig ist und immer viel guckt und schaut. Und das kann man sich nämlich auch mit den Mac-Ports installieren, jetzt. Und das Paket dafür heißt MP4-V2. Das ist so eine Library, wo so allerlei Tools drin sind und die generell einem Programm eine API bereitstellen, um halt in MP4 irgendwie Zeug zu machen. Das ist an sich eine sehr coole Basis, um so mit Medien-Dateien in der nächsten Zukunft mal auch, weißt du, dass man da halt mal richtige Dateien liefern kann mit Metadaten, mit Bildern, mit Links, mit Kapiteln, mit Papapap und you name it. Und das hat lange gefehlt. Und vor allem die Tools, die es gab, hatten auf Mac Probleme zu compilen. Keine Probleme hatte ich jetzt über die Mac-Ports, das installieren, wer das mal ausprobieren will, macht einfach sudo port install mp4-v2 und dann gibt es da ein Tool, das heißt mp4-chaps, mp4-chap-ters. Das ter haben sie sich dann noch gespart, weil es geht ja nicht um so lange Namen zu benutzen. Da kommt man dann hin, da würde sich das ja alles noch selbst erklären und das verhindert ja den Großvisierstatus.
Da ist ein mp4-v2 dabei, ja?
Genau. Also wenn du das installierst, dann kommt das einfach so mit. Dann heißt das mp4-chaps. Und das ist dann auch tod einfach. Du brauchst einfach nur eine Textdatei, in der steht einfach ein Timecode, Stunde, Minute, Sekunde, Frame-Nummer. Und dann dahinter einen, da bin ich dann komplett vom Stuhl gefallen, einen UTF-8-Strikt. Also er macht halt auch Unicode, Umlaut usw. Was vorher auch mal das Problem war mit den Tools, die überhaupt irgendwas konnten, die sind dann natürlich gleich die Karten gelegt, wenn da irgendwie mal ein Ü kam oder so.
21.
21. Jahrhundert, jetzt auch in mp4-Dateien.
Und er braucht keine zusätzlichen Bibliotheken, wenn ich das richtig sehe. Kompiliert einfach so, braucht keine zusätzlichen Bibliotheken. Ich dachte, dass er jetzt so ein ganzer Strang nachkommt an...
Hast du einfach schon alles installiert?
Das kann natürlich auch sein.
Das kann schon sein. Also, ein paar Sachen. Ja gut, aber es ist halt eine Low-Level-File-Library. Ich wüsste jetzt auch nicht, was er da groß noch nach sich ziehen sollte. Aber kann natürlich sein, dass du schon den Kram hattest. Leider kann man sich beim Mac-Ports nicht so ohne weiteres mal anschauen, worauf was ein Port noch mit installieren würde.
Du kannst nur die erste Ebene von Dependencies angucken, aber nicht den ganzen Dependency-Baum.
Wie macht man die erste Ebene?
Port Deps oder Port Dependents. Ein von beiden. Deps oder Dependents.
Hab ich da was übersehen? Wahrscheinlich.
Port Deps.
Achso, Deps und Dependents.
Eins ist nach oben und eins ist runter. Also eins sagt dir, worauf diese...
Ach, Depends und sind die Dependents. Deps ist ein Alias für Info, Pretty, Full Name, Depends.
Pretty.
Also Deps zeigt dir an, worauf zum Beispiel MySQL Dependent und Dependents zeigt dir, was alles auf MySQL Dependent sozusagen.
Okay, MP4-V2 Dependent nur auf Help 2-Mann. Help to Manual.
Ah, das ist wahrscheinlich irgendein Konvertierungs-Dingsbumm.
Das ist bestimmt irgendein komischer Konvertierungs-Dingsbumm.
Was haben wir mal mit schöneren Mobile-Max-Fach ein bisschen Behaftigkeit gesagt?
Was, Vivo? Na gut, dann geht das aber weiter. Wenn die Library-Dependents zieht, kommt gleich Pearl-5 hinterher. Gate-Takes, Lib-Alkons und so. Da ist schon ein ganzer Rattenschanz voll fubar dahinten dran, wie das immer so ist, aber gut, das ist halt nun mal so unter Augenlos.
Wann machen wir denn jetzt mal los mit der Sendung?
Wir sind im Prinzip schon mittendrin. Nein, ich hab schon meine ersten zwei Punkte abgehakt. Und bevor ich das auch noch total vergesse, muss ich eigentlich noch mal eine Mail rausdingsen. Mir hat einer eine Mail geschrieben, der Admin ist an einer Schule und irgendwie zwanghaft versucht, dort Macintosh als Standard durchzusetzen.
Ich hoffe nicht zwanghaft.
Auf jeden Fall haben die da irgendwie gerade alles auf Performer-Level noch irgendwie. Er fragte mich, ob ich denn nicht...
Museum, ein bisschen Geld, da können sie richtig dicke Rechner kaufen.
Er fragte mich, ob ich denn nicht wüsste, wo man irgendwie so alte Macs irgendwie kriegt. Alte Macs, die nicht uralter sind. Sie haben eigentlich eher antike Klasse. Ich meine, wir reden hier von 68.000er Technologie.
Performer? Stimmt, die gab es noch nicht mal mit PowerPC.
Performer 475. Diese Pizzaschachtel.
Ja, da gab es alle möglichen Performers. Das war ja diese Zeit, wo alles ganz unübersichtlich war. Das war so kurz vor der PowerPC-Migration. Es kann auch sein, dass es jetzt schon PowerPC-Performers sind. Hier steht nur Performers. Wie auch immer. Also falls irgendjemand, keine Ahnung, PowerPC-Class irgendwie vor fünf Jahren, Rechner, die heute eigentlich keiner mehr haben will, irgendwie eine Lastwagen-Ladung voll hat und die nicht unbedingt jetzt noch für 50 Euro auf eBay vertickern will, sondern eine Schule glücklich machen soll, soll uns eine Mail schreiben.
Oh Gott, ich hab neulich ein Video auf Twitter gestellt, wie ich ein Powerbook G4 so...
Ja, das war ganz schön hart. Ich hab ein bisschen geweint.
Ja, ich auch.
Warum hast du denn das gemacht?
Weil das total tot war. Also das Display war im Arsch, das Motherboard war gebrochen, sodass die Grafikkarte nicht mehr ging, die Platte war durch, also da war wirklich nichts mehr dran.
Das Gehäuse?
Das Gehäuse ist runtergerotzt.
Ich wette dir, du hättest dafür noch was bekommen.
Ja, hätte ich vielleicht noch was bekommen.
Ich hab neulich wieder versucht, gebrauchte Macs zu kaufen. Ich guck immer mal wieder so, mal so ein Mac Mini, der ein paar Jahre alt ist und so. Du weißt ja, zu so einem Decent Price, wo man sich sagt, nehm ich mit. Das ist nicht möglich. Also drei Jahre alte Mac Minis, teilweise sogar mit noch älterer, die Core Solo.
Okay, geht über neuer Preis.
Geht nicht unter 300 Euro weg. Also das ist total absurd. Du kannst mal Glück haben, dass du mal einen erwischt, wo jetzt wirklich, was weiß ich, der sich vertippt hat. Das haben nicht genug Leute auf der Beobachtungsnetze, aber alte Macintoshes sind einfach so nachgefragt. Es ist absurd.
Vor allem, wenn er jetzt noch auf dem 68er Performer ist und dann so ein G5, sag mal, so den ersten G5, dann kriegt er, ist das ja für ihn auch so, nochmal...
Würde der Schule schon was bringen, auch wenn ich ehrlich gesagt glaube, Mac Minis wären wahrscheinlich die ideale Bestückung. Die wären wahrscheinlich mit so einer Core Solo-Nummer auch noch ganz zufrieden. Aber kannst ja auch die leisten, irgendwie so 10 Dinger. Da hast du ja auch schon wieder 5000 Euro, die du da weg bist.
Dieser Geschwindigkeitsunterschied dann trotzdem.
Dann denkst du dir, boah...
Ich hab Bolli, der hat ja bis Anfang des Jahres noch seinen Titanium-Powerbook G4 genutzt. Mit 667 MHz. Und er hat sich ja dann auch so einen MacBook Pro geschoppt. Und er ist auch fast vom Stuhl gefallen. Dann hat er so, Flash ruckelt nicht mehr, ich kann YouTube-Videos gucken.
Was? Flash ruckelt nicht mehr auf dem Mac Pro?
Er konnte YouTube-Videos vorher halt nicht ruckelfrei gucken.
Ach so, gar nicht nie. Jetzt nur noch manchmal. So, jetzt hab ich schon meinen dritten Punkt weg. Jetzt haben wir ja viel über Wave geredet, zum zweiten Mal in der letzten Ausgabe. Dann haben wir es mal ausprobiert. Und angefangen haben wir mit einer kleinen Themenliste für uns. Und dann, wer war schuld?
Ich war wieder schuld.
Du hast gesagt, man könnte doch mal und man müsste doch mal.
Genau, das hab ich gesagt.
Und dann haben wir doch mal. Das Ergebnis ist, dass da jetzt mittlerweile 264 Beiträge gelandet sind. Da ich das letzte Mal geguckt habe, sind wieder 77 dazugegangen. In einer Wave, da lernt man allerdings auch eine Menge darüber, was Wave alles noch nicht leistet.
Drucken zum Beispiel.
Ja, das ist doch absurd, oder?
Ich meine, jetzt hast du da irgendwie dieses riesen Teil an Informationen und du kannst es noch nicht mal ausdrucken. Gespeichert, dass man da halbwegs schnell durchscrollen könnte.
Mein Safari sagt jetzt Slow Script.
Ja, also nicht, dass mein Safari crasht, aber das Wave sagt, ich komm jetzt hier gerade nicht hinterher.
Dieses spezielle Wave sagt, mein Safari, da geht nichts mehr.
Aber da kann man ja mal gucken, ob...
Das ist absurd, oder?
Wave ist das neue Flash.
Du, Adobe hat auch ein eigenes Wave. Es gibt auch ein Produkt, das heißt Adobe Wave.
Really?
Ich hab bloß keine Ahnung, was es ist. Ich glaub, jeder hat ein Produkt, was Wave heißt. Ich glaub sogar Microsoft hat so was. Aber so richtig, ja... Genau kann ich es dir jetzt auch nicht sagen. Ja, jetzt ist die Frage, wie gehen wir da ran?
An diese Liste? Ich probier sie erstmal aufzumachen.
Also Top-Themen sind auf jeden Fall irgendwie Wave. Wir haben irgendwie Microsoft. Wir haben nochmal Microsoft. Ich hab mir notiert, man könnte sich ja mal ein bisschen über das Stockholm-Syndrom unterhalten.
Stockholm-Syndrom?
Wir gucken zu wenig Fernsehen, Jungs. Das ist dann jeden zweiten Krimi irgendwie.
Das ist dieses, dass man sich mit seinem Entführer identifiziert?
Genau. Nach einer Weile, ja.
Und das in Bezug worauf?
Ich meine, kennst du einen anderen Grund, warum man jetzt irgendwie so an der Plattform kleben sollte, außer dass man angefangen hat, seinen Entführer zu lieben?
Sein Reiniger.
Ich meine jetzt, wie sie wieder alle in Gold.
Ich glaube, das hat aber einen anderen Grund.
Windows 7, die Befreiung irgendwie. Ja, so, jetzt wird alles gut. Ich fand ja auch, die neuen Werbespots, die Apple da released hat, der eine geht ja im Prinzip genau drauf ein. Hast du schon gesehen?
Ja, ja, ich hab sie gesehen. Ich hab sie jetzt bloß...
Trust Me.
Diesmal wird alles gut.
Dann spulen sie das irgendwie komplett zurück zu jedem Windows Release. Jetzt brauch ich wahrscheinlich gar nicht mehr nachfragen. Ich hab ja bei Microsoft nicht beim Presse-Service angemeldet. Ah, du wolltest Windows 7 bekommen. Und lass mir jetzt ein Windows 7 zuschicken.
Und die schicken ja auch einfach so eins.
Also die Antwort war, ja, machen wir sobald wir Presse-Exemplare haben.
Ach toll. Was habt ihr deshalb für Exemplare? Ist das nochmal eine andere Version dieser Produkt-Matrix?
Wahrscheinlich von einem Geldschein drinnen.
Das ist eine Extramatrix. Vielleicht haben die irgendwie...
Ist das Ding jetzt so weg gerade, dass die nicht mal welche für dich pressen? Doch, seit... Ja, irgendwie sowas. Seit gestern oder vorgestern.
Soll ja auch auf dem Mac laufen, hab ich gehört.
22. Vorgestern. Ja, offiziell. Wobei da hat sich jetzt auch nicht so viel getan. Also diese Version, die jetzt verkauft wird, die ist als solche auch schon eine Weile unterwegs.
Ja, die ist schon über OEM und weiß ja trotzdem was.
Na, hier irgendwie Ziegenbärtchen. Mosberg meint ja, das wär jetzt alles ganz toll. Das wär ja genau so gut wie Snorlapart. Wobei ich bin ja jetzt im Nachgang zu unserer letzten Sendung tatsächlich auf ein Feature gestoßen, was bei Windows 7 dabei ist. Ich weiß nicht, ob das schon bei Vista dabei war. Kann auch sein. Was ich echt geil finde. Was ich auch auf dem Mac haben will.
Was denn? Alle installer?
Du kannst, du hast da automatisch einen Mixer dabei für jedes laufende Programm. Und du kannst halt sagen, dieses Programm soll jetzt keinen Sound machen. Das geht einfach nicht auf diesem scheiß Mac. Und ich hab verschiedene Tipps bekommen, wie man das mit irgendwelchen Tools machen kann. Bei AudioHadric Pro und so weiter hab ich alles schon lange gekauft. Bei Rook Amöber bin ich sowieso irgendwie Stammkunde und hab, glaub ich, 50% der Ratus gekauft, weil die die einzigen sind, die mit Audio irgendwie umgehen können auf dem Mac. Aber es gibt sowas nicht. Und ich versteh das nicht. Bzw. ich hab natürlich eine Verschwörungstheorie, warum sie sowas nicht haben. Aber es ist albern. Es ist doch ein... Wie soll ich erzählen? Die Verschwörungstheorie. Ach so, naja, wegen iTunes und DIM und Mitschneiden, diesen ganzen Climp-In, machen sie das irgendwie nicht so oft. Aber es ist albern, weil es gibt irgendwie Soundflower und jeder weiß, wie einfach man irgendwie Sound mitschneiden kann. Oder hier mit Audio, Hijack Pro, also diese ganzen Tools von Rook am Möber, die basieren ja überhaupt erst mal auf diesem Hijacking. Mir ist nicht ganz klar, auf welcher Ebene bei Core Audio sie da einsetzen, aber so ganz so schlimm kann es nicht sein. Im Prinzip installieren sie sich da halt einfach als... Ja, weiß nicht genau, als Element, in irgendeiner Form sind sie in der Lage, diese Audioströme auf jeden Fall umzuleiten und sie können Programme hijacken und so weiter. Das heißt, einerseits werden sie in der Lage, so ein Produkt rauszubringen, andererseits finde ich es einfach absurd, dass das nicht sowieso schon einfach so mit dabei ist. Ich find's einfach blöd, weil du kannst nicht einfach mal ein Programm stummschalten. Ich hab mal in irgendeiner App, irgendeine Apple Browser Patent, war noch mal drin, wo sie dann auch einen Lautstärkeregler im Browserfenster hat.
Ja, das ist total...
Warum gibt's das noch nicht?
Ich hätte ja gerne so einen Tab, wenn er gerade nicht aktiv ist, und da kommt Musik, so Töne raus, dass man so Wellen sieht, die weggehen, und man sofort weiß, welchen Tab, von dem ich jetzt stummschalten muss.
Ich glaub, so was heißt Internet Explorer. Das ist halt der Punkt. Manchmal hat Microsoft ja wirklich innovative Details.
Das kann man echt nicht anders sagen.
Ey, ich erzähl mir jetzt auch ein Windows-Scheiße.
Die haben da dann ein Konflikt bei Windows 7.
Wieso hängt denn hier dieses Windows-7-T-Shirt drauf?
Ihr wolltet euch doch, dass ich zu meiner Home Party einkaufe. Das ist unsere Windows-7-Launch-Party hier. Ja, mit Soft Cakes. Und Michael, der ist schuld. Und ja, all den ganzen Karten.
Gibt's hier noch ein bisschen Soft Cake?
Okay, du dachtest, du bist bei Macintosh Podcast.
Ich gebe jetzt zu, ich hab auch schon Windows 7 hier laufen auf meinem Mac und hab das nur mit Mac OS geskinnt, damit es nicht gleich aufhält.
Soft Cake? Also weicher Keks aufs Windows? Passt doch irgendwie zusammen. Gib mal noch einen bitte.
Es gibt genug. Ah, der Chat ist schon besorgt.
So, dann installieren wir gleich noch Office.
Habt ihr das mitbekommen mit dem Datenverlust von Sidekick? Ist ja wirklich keine Big News.
Ist ja auch schon aufgehoben, oder? Haben sie doch alles retten können?
Ja, sie haben es retten können. Das war wohl so, dass sie an der Stelle ein Fail hatten, sowohl das Backup als auch die richtigen Daten betroffen sind. Das heißt, ihr Fail lag darin, dass auch ihre Backups irgendwie zerschoben wurden. Ich würde sagen, die haben so einen Scheißschwein gehabt.
Also ich habe irgendwas gelesen, dass die Daten, die Platten waren wohl alle okay, aber die haben irgendein Firmware-Update machen wollen und danach kamen sie in die Daten nicht mehr ran. Deswegen konnten sie auch nichts zurückspielen, weil sie an alle Daten nicht mehr ran kamen, egal was sie gemacht hatten.
Die haben bestimmt Drobo benutzt.
Ja, ich hab ihn nicht verkauft, weil ich hab da jetzt sowieso Daten drauf, aber ich hab kein besonders gutes Gefühl dabei, ihn täglich zu benutzen. Immerhin hat er aufgehört, dass wenn ich ihn jetzt einschalte, die eine Platte dann nicht mitzuerkennen. Also er erkennt jetzt nach dem Einschalten alle Platten, ohne dass ich da irgendwas gemacht hab. Es gab jetzt auch ein Drobo-Firmware-Update, vielleicht hat das irgendwas gebracht, keine Ahnung, ich hab das jetzt nicht so intensiv getestet, aber immerhin tut sich da was, das ist ja schon mal ganz hilfreich. Also das Ding hat eine neue Firmware, vielleicht läuft er jetzt besser, ich hab jetzt keine weiteren Probleme gehabt, aber ich verwende ihn halt dann doch nicht mit Time Machine zusammen, aus den schon mehrfach hier erläuterten Gründen.
Damit kommen wir gleich beim Thema jetzt?
Genau, und ich dachte ja irgendwie, ich dachte ja, alles wird gut und irgendwie ZFS ist coming. Es sieht nicht gut aus, oder was ist das jetzt?
Max macht hier Freudenssprünge.
ZFS ist nicht ins Snow Leopard gelandet, ich hab gesagt, ruhig Blut Leute, mit 10, 6, 5 wird alles gut. Dann haben sie irgendwie angefangen, ein Fallsystem-Ingenieur zu suchen, da gibt es jetzt irgendwie eine Open-Job-Description.
Und auch wirklich seit gestern oder vorgestern, also wirklich ganz frisch.
Und jetzt frisch vor dieser Sendung, oder? Ist zfsmacosforge.org, ist das die URL? Ist irgendwie This Project Has Been Discontinued steht da.
Ja, also ich bin ja da auf dieser Liste auch subscribt, so aus Fun und ist auch immer ganz putzig da gewesen. Und dann kam halt gestern bei einem Gläubigen, die sind auch wirklich so, ist egal, und wir patchen das zur Not selber und wir fahren das, egal was kommt, so. Sind dann ein paar drauf und dann kam halt gestern so auf einen dieser Mails als Antwort, übrigens ist jetzt offiziell vorbei mit Link auf die Seite, dann haben wir alle drauf geklickt, nein. Dann haben sie gleich eine eigene Mailing-Liste auf Google aufgemacht und den Code darüber gezogen und alles, aber dann bebte das so durchs Netz, so übers Twitter, ist ja auch gleich rausgepustet.
Was, was, was, was geht da ab?
Na, das war ja einfach sowieso schon extrem lange da ruhig so. Ich weiß nicht, diese Noelle, ist das eigentlich ein Typ oder eine Frau? Eine Frau. Das war ja da auf dieser Liste auch die einzige von Apple, die sich da mal irgendwie geäußert hatte.
Das ist eine ehemalige Sun-Angestellte, die wohl zu Apple rübergewandert ist. Und ich glaub seit Anfang letzten Jahres, so März oder so, seitdem ist da nichts mehr passiert. Also so richtig gar nichts mehr.
Also ich hab irgendwie die Archive mal durchgeblättet und im August oder so hat sie mal eine Mail geschrieben, sodass sie so noch mitliest und irgendwie gelegentlich reinguckt, aber mehr hat sie dann halt auch nicht gesagt. Und in der Zwischenzeit... Diesen August. Ja, hat sie halt noch mal kurz gesagt, ich guck noch mal gelegentlich rein, aber es...
Und ich hab ihr eine Mail geschrieben, hab gefragt, ob sie noch bei Apple arbeitet und ob sie noch an ZFs arbeitet. Hat sie geantwortet, bei Apple ist sie noch. Aber für irgendwelche internen Projekte kann sie keine Auskunft erteilen.
Naja, und auf jeden Fall ist halt... Ja, ist jetzt da halt offiziell Schluss. Also es war halt die ganze Zeit unklar. Die haben halt nichts mehr released auf Mac OS Fort. War einfach ruhig, kein Statement, kein Nix. Und jetzt ist halt so, nachdem sich wahrscheinlich auf der Liste einfach genug beschwert haben, dass sie doch wenigstens mal eine Ansage machen sollen, ob es jetzt noch weitergeht oder nicht. Haben sie halt gesagt, geht nicht mehr weiter.
Bestieft.
Bei John Gruber stand da das angeblich, hat das Legal Team irgendwie das zurückgefiffen. Das ist nett wegen irgendwie, weil wie heißt diese andere Storage-Bude? NetApp, genau. Die haben da irgendwelche Patente und das würde sich wohl mit ZFest streiten und das ist wohl ein bisschen unklar und deswegen ist Apple das irgendwie zu heiß gewesen oder irgendwie so die Story. Aber ehrlich gesagt glaube ich das nicht.
Also es war halt schon so, dass sie das runtergenommen haben von der Apple-Seite, war schon so in dem Zeitraum, wo halt Oracle auch Sun gekauft hatte. Also das war halt, war schon so in dem Zeitraum.
Aber oft gehört, Transylkon haben sie doch vor ca. 2 Jahren schon. Danach ist ja nichts mehr passiert. Also im Frühling letzten Jahr, sagen wir mal so.
Aber in den Betas war es doch noch drin? Was, gab es nur Leopard Betas mit ZFS?
Aber da war ja auch nichts mehr passiert eigentlich.
Aber die Bildnummer war noch weiter. Na ja, anyway, auf jeden Fall wird jetzt halt gerade in der Rumorszene gemutmaßt, dass es halt zum einen mit Oracle kauft Sun und damit auch ZFS zu tun hat, weil Oracle halt auch ein eigenes Next Generation Fallsystem seit Jahren schon entwickelt. Nämlich dieses sogenannte Butter FS oder BTR FS. Echt?
Also, Oracle hat da wohl mit angefangen, aber irgendwann haben sie sich dann doch zurückgezogen.
Ja, die haben damit angefangen.
Eigentlich sollte es schon längst draußen sein, aber es ist halt immer noch nicht. Und dann haben sie halt irgendwie Sun gekauft und ja dann, also keine Ahnung, so richtig genau weiß es halt noch keiner.
Ist alles ein bisschen unklar.
Man mutmaßt halt, Apple hat einfach keinen Bock gehabt, weil das jetzt irgendwie...
Aha, nett, was ist denn das für eine Brille?
Aber ich meine, die FreeBSD und NetBSD jetzt auch schon und Linux soll jetzt wohl auch so irgendwie in einen besseren Port kommen. Also die machen das ja alle und warum machen die das und warum kann Apple das nicht auch so weiter pflegen? Also das ist ein bisschen unklar. Ich glaube, Herr Steve ist gekommen, oder wer auch immer von seinen Minions da und meinte hier ZFS, was, Pool, was, Snapshots und dann Clone und Hä? Hä, tausend Features? Viel zu kompliziert, gestieft.
Ey, ich sag mal, könnt ihr nicht noch hier irgendwie Snapshots an ZFS plus ran nageln?
Worum geht's denn hier alles? Es geht um Copy und Write, es geht um breitable Snapshots und es geht um Snapshots an sich.
Ja, also die NetApp-Jungs sagen halt genau das, womit ZFS posten, nämlich hier Copy and Write, Trees und was nicht alles. Und sie sind das erste Commercial-Filesystem, was diese Features hat. Sagt NetApp genau, das ist eigentlich...
Alles irrt.
Was haben die da irgendwie außer so einem Scheiß-Patent?
Im Zweifel reicht das ja erstmal.
Waffel. Die Leute, die sollen gehen.
Was bilden die sich ein? Es kann ja auch sein, dass Oracle sagt, ja, so richtig wissen wir jetzt auch nicht, ob wir hier mit ZFS weitermachen. Vielleicht gibt es ja da auch von Oracle einfach nicht so eine konkrete Ansage an alle anderen, die das benutzen wollen.
Aber Apple, die fangen noch nicht an und importieren da einfach, ohne zu wissen, wie es aussieht, sondern die müssen auch irgendwelche Verträge haben mit Sun. Also entweder hatten sie die oder das ist halt einfach eine DDL, das ist irgendwie frei, und dann legst du einfach los. Die legen auch noch nicht los, ohne zu wissen, wie es in der Zukunft irgendwie abgehen wird.
Tja, man weiß es nicht so genau.
Ich denke, das war denen zu kompliziert und da haben die das geknickt.
Ich meine, die haben ja halt auch so einen Half S Plus so viel, also nicht komischer, also sicher sinnvolle Features, aber noch so mit dran genagelt, mit ihren File Compression Foo und Source Forks und so eine Half S X.
Half S Plus Plus?
Nee, Half S X.
Also ich hatte letztens erst irgendwie ein kaputtes Half S Plus, weil ich irgendwie mal booten musste, weil mal wieder irgendwie der hier gefriest ist oder was auch immer und danach war mein File System kaputt.
Ja, aber dann rennen sie doch gegen die gleiche Patentmauer wie auch Sun.
Die können ja dann im Zweifel halt irgendwie die Lizenzgebühren bezahlen.
Wieso geht Steve nicht einfach zu seinem Freund Larry und dann denken die sich irgendwie was aus, wie sie diesen Jungs da Büroklammern auf die Schwänze stecken können. Ich meine, das geht doch einfach nicht.
Ja, aber vielleicht ist ja, guck mal, also ZFS und so ist ja alles gut und schön und so. Ist ja auch jetzt hier Next Generation Most Advanced File System. Aber sind halt auch so die ersten. Da gibt es ja auch so die eine oder andere Ecke, die noch nicht so ganz optimal ist. Also gibt es ja auch irgendwie von...
Jerofa.
Na, was war denn das hier irgendwie? So spontan weiß ich das jetzt auch nicht, aber... Also zum Beispiel gibt es ja hier auch dieses... Was zum Beispiel Apple auch irgendwie gar nicht gefallen hat, ist halt... Das ist ja sowieso ein generelles Problem, dass halt diese... Mit USB-Drives und so funktioniert der ZFS nicht so gut. Zum Beispiel so external USB-Drives.
Haben sie schon gefixt.
Das Problem war, dass so ein USB-Drive oder auch viele andere Hardware-Geräte und Festplatte den Schicksal wie Daten und das Gerät sagt dann, okay, hab ich geschrieben. Oder ZFS muss ich halt drauf verlassen. Und das war aber noch gar nicht geschrieben. Das geht nicht bei ZFS. Also das ist nicht so gut. Und noch viel Schlimmeres ist, du schickst irgendwie hin, schreib mal A und dann schreib mal B. Und die schreiben aber zuerst B und dann stürzt es ab. Aber A wurde nie geschrieben. Also die schreiben nicht in der richtigen Reihenfolge. Wenn du dann einen Absturz hast, dann ist zum Beispiel so ein Überblock, der bei ZFS immer am wichtigsten und der ist geschrieben, aber die passende A, dann ist es nicht geschrieben. Wenn das ZFS dann buten würde, liest er den Überblock, findet er dann die passenden Daten dafür nicht und dann ist es im Arsch. Haben sie aber irgendwie alles erkannt, deswegen suchen sie jetzt, wenn der erste Überblock eine Seite passenden Daten nicht hat, dann nehmen sie den von zehn Sekunden vorher, was auch immer, weil ja immer Copy-on-Wite ist. Der Halter liegt da auf jeden Fall auch rum. Haben sie diese ganzen Customer-Probleme, würde ich sagen, hier so ein normaler Standard, Joy-User-Probleme, haben sie irgendwie erkannt und machen sie voll am Rumfixen.
Vielleicht sind sie einfach auf Größen wahnsinnig genug und sagen irgendwie, wir machen das einfach selber. Wir machen jetzt Worlds Most Advanced, Filesystem irgendwie, wir nehmen jetzt immer ZFS und die anderen, die es dazu gibt, schon so als Inspiration. Aber wir machen jetzt nochmal unser eigenes Ding. Machen sie dann bestimmt auch Open Source, dass sie dann möglichst auch gleich bei Freebase, die und alle anderen das dann gleich mit implementieren sollen.
Wir hätten ja gleich so wie mit WebKit, gleich irgendwie so forken und selber aufsetzen und durchziehen.
Also ich hab ja meine Zweifel. Ich hab ja so meine Zweifel. Ich meine, sie haben zwar jetzt durchaus Fortschritte da gemacht mit ihrem Filesystem, aber eigentlich ist das immer alles noch total all. Na, Apple. Na ja, ist halt diese Kompression eingebaut und überhaupt das Plus war ja nun gegenüber dem HFS schon eine signifizierte Verbesserung.
Dieses Journaling bringt nicht so wirklich was. Wenn deine Kiste abkackt, dann ist dein System einfach mal im Eimer und dann bootest du und machst irgendwie von Hand so einen F-Check und dann sagt er dir, ja, da hätten aber irgendwie 12 Milliarden Deer Entries sein müssen, du hattest aber nur 4 Milliarden Deer Entries und ich muss jetzt mal eine Stunde reparieren. Das darf nicht sein, ich dachte, dafür ist der Journaling da. Der guckt danach, was geschrieben wurde, wo noch nicht geschrieben wurde, dann kann er das irgendwie fixen und dann ist alles wieder schön, aber nee.
Naja, auf jeden Fall ist es dann wohl so, wenn sie jetzt gerade erst einen Engineer überhaupt suchen und jetzt gerade erst ZFS ablasen, dass wir dann wohl bis Meco S XX dann auch schön warten können, bis dann irgendwie HF SX auch sich reinfixed.
Was für ein Dreck. Ich meine, jetzt mit dem ganzen Scheiß nochmal von vorne anzufangen. Vor allem Copy und Writ. Ich meine, das will man eh haben. Oder? Ich meine...
Ich würde mich nicht wundern, wenn da mal einer richtig nachguckt und Prior Art findet.
Ja klar, ich meine, eigentlich müssen sie nur diesen Scheiß da durchbringen. Aber warum, weiß ich nicht, warum das Apple das dann gleich so sein lässt? Ja gut, andererseits ist es auch nicht ihr Ding, an Sachen zu arbeiten, die sie dann nicht zielgerichtet auch in irgendeine Release reinpushen können. Vielleicht haben sie es einfach nur...
Und diese nicht genug beeinflussen können. Vielleicht hat Oracle schon gesagt, wenn wir Sun kaufen, dann helfen wir euch nicht mehr. Da müsst ihr alleine klarkommen. Wobei das Apple schon Sun-Programmiere-Einkauf im ZFS-Team war. Also ich meine, was willst du dann noch mehr haben? Musst du auch Reichen einkaufen.
Kann ja auch sein, dass die jetzt irgendwie wo so lange Sachen im ZFS vorbei sind, schön Fallsystem-Engineers von Sun abkaufen.
Was ist denn das überhaupt für eine Brude? NetApp.
So wie MC-Quadraten und glaube ich ein bisschen kleiner.
Bietet eine integrierte Lösung an für Storage-Delivery und Management von Daten.
Faselblatt.
Ich schlafe noch mal eine Runde.
Mach mal.
Findest du nicht so spannend oder was?
Auch geht so.
We are working to enhance the user experience of our website. Na wie wär's mal, die User Experience auf meinem Computer zu enhancing, indem wir diesen Scheiß last? Ach man, ey.
Vielleicht ist ja auch NetApp zu Apple getreten und hat gesagt, hört mal zu, Jungs, wir lizenzieren unser Waffel da für euch und Apple hat gesagt, okay, ist ja viel weniger.
Ja gut, ich mein, dann sollen die sich irgendwie einigen. Ich bin sauer. Z-Dead.
Nee, ich hab's ihm aber auch, glaub ich. Ich hab's ihm gesteckt auch, ja.
Steffan, das ist der Titel hier. Z-Dead, baby. Ich bin noch nicht hinterhergekommen mit den Updates.
Also bei Grubber stand das ja auch so in etwa, dass es halt irgendwie... Also der Grubber behauptet eben, das ist vom...
Ja, ich glaub da ehrlich gesagt nicht so wirklich dran. Egal, was jetzt noch gerade rauskommt, es gibt ja diesen Netatalk Demon, der ist sozusagen der Apple-File-Protokoll-Demon für Unix-Systeme. Das heißt, du kannst ja irgendwie ein FreeBest oder Linux oder was auch immer irgendwie aufsetzen, machst da diesen Netatalk an und kannst dann den Home oder irgendwelche anderen Partitionen genauso anbieten wie... Na wie, dass man mit dem Apple halt draufkommt, per AFP. Und da gibt es dennächst eine neue Version, die 205, weil 204 ist gerade aktuell. Und bei der 205 steht da, dass sie jetzt auch Time Machine Support haben. Und ich wüsste nicht, was sie genau damit meinen. Ich dachte, naja, machen sie nur das im Pfeilsystem, denn dieses Time Machine Support, das irgendwie feil existiert.
Das ist auf jeden Fall schon mal.
Aber? Nee, das musst du ja selber setzen. Oder vielleicht machen die das so hinten, dass es automatisch immer mit Yes beantwortet wird, wenn du so einen Pfeil abfragst. Aber es ist wohl, das Time Machine hier auf dem Klein macht wohl auf einem Remote Storage erst mal so ein Disk Image, wenn es das nicht lokal speichert. Und um dieses Disk Image zu erstellen, da gibt es ja so Anleitungen, wie man das alles schon zusammenhackt. Und das funktioniert nicht, dass dieses Time Machine von alleine dieses Disk Image auf einem Nicht-Apple-Rechner stellt, weil die da irgendwelche Kommandos benutzen, die das Netatalk vorher nie hatte. Vielleicht ist das irgendwas ganz Neues, was irgendwie im Protokoll noch nicht lange drin ist. Oder irgendwie so.
Eine neue Version sozusagen. Also eine neue Version von dem Protokoll, von dem AFP-Protokoll.
Genau, dass sie neue Features nutzen, den Protokoll, den Netatalk noch nicht hatte. Deswegen konnte man dieses Disk Image nicht angelegt werden. Deswegen sagen diese Anleitungen, wo man sich so ein Time Machine-Backup da irgendwie so zusammenschrauben muss von Hand, dass man sich dieses Image von alleine anlegen soll, es soll genauso heiß wie der Rechner, damit der das erkennt und so. Und dann soll man es auf dieses Remote Volume drauflegen und dann wird das erkennt und kann dann seine Backups darauf machen. Und so wie es jetzt ist, ist dann halt in Netatalk 205, da gibt es schon Release Candidate 3, der unterstützt wohl diese Kommandos. Das heißt, dann kann Time Machine von selbst dieses Disk Image anlegen und dann fallen diese ganzen Schritte weg, die es einem doch relativ kompliziert machen. Nein, nicht wirklich kompliziert, aber so damit der normalsterbliche User auch das viel einfacher benutzen kann.
Und unterstützen sie dann, also, Städtler, auch was davon, ob sie sich auch genauso verhalten wie eine Time Capsule, das hier auch über hier Dingenskirchen, Avaii, Bonjour, sich irgendwie melden.
Das musst du noch selber machen.
Ja, weil das ist ja eigentlich der Clou, ne? Du klappst irgendwie deinen Teil auf und dann sieht er, ah, da ist meine Time Capsule.
Das ist schon klar, aber ich glaube, das kommt vielleicht auch noch in Netator.
Ja, einen String irgendwie anzunähren.
Eigentlich ist es nicht schwer. Dieser MTDAPD, der macht das ja auch von selbst. Den startest du und der annunzt dich gleich von selber, indem er diese MDNS Responder-Lib oder den Code sich da reinkopiert. Da ist ja auch überhaupt nicht viel Code, das ist nur ganz bisschen. Und das könnten die bei Netator auch machen. Also ich würde mal sagen, wenn das alles schick läuft demnächst, dann ist das der nächste Schritt, den die da machen. Weil es gibt natürlich nichts Cooles. Dieses Netator ist eh so ein bisschen ins Hintertreffen geraten, weil sie alle irgendwie Samba und Zeug machen und was weiß ich nicht alles. Aber genau, ich bin auch mehr so ein Netator-Fan. Aber da muss ein bisschen mehr passieren. Und wenn jetzt Time Machine benutzen und mehr Leute sind, dann könnte ich ja mir schön remote so ein Backup Storage machen. Zum Beispiel auf einem ZFS dann auch, ne Max?
Stimmt, dann könnte das auch auf FreeBSD.
Läuft das Netator jetzt auf FreeBSD irgendwie zuverlässig?
Ja, hab ich zu Hause und woanders auch im Einsatz.
Ich hab mir früher mal ganz früchte Daten irgendwie zerschrottet damit.
Also Netator hat mir auch schon mal vor Ewigkeiten Daten gekillt.
Das ist fast 10 Jahre her.
Eigentlich tut sich da was.
Aber das wär doch cool, ne?
Du hast aber dein ZFS und das Time Machine macht dann natürlich trotzdem wieder dieses Disk Image darauf. Also dieses Fast Image.
Ja, okay, gut, das lässt sich halt nicht ändern. Aber immerhin hast du das Ganze auf einer ZFS-Basis. Und das funktioniert ja bei dem neuen FreeBSD. Es ist ja jetzt auch Out of the Box mit dabei, oder? Wenn die da nicht auch irgendwie in Patentprobleme sind.
Keine Ahnung, also bei 8.0 jetzt, was irgendwie Release Candidate 1 gerade ist, ist ein ZFS dabei und das ist rock'n'roll stable, würde ich mal behaupten, inzwischen. Und das läuft super. Wir haben übrigens hier Hucke hier, ist ja mein Freund vom Klub hier. Wir haben da so einen dicken Fileserver mit unseren Chaos-Archiven. Und da sind irgendwie zwei Terabyte drauf oder sowas. Und ich hab mal geguckt letztens und wir hatten noch nie einen einzigen ZFS-Fehler. Oder auch kein Plattenfehler, also ist alles irgendwie Error-free.
Sagt das ZFS?
Nein, nein. Hier passt alles.
Ich bin voll gut.
Liebe mich.
Ich konnte keinen Fehler entdecken. Es lebe ZFS.
Also ich muss sagen, ganz ehrlich, ich...
Jetzt hat er dir den letzten Keks gegessen.
Ich bin jetzt tatsächlich, ist ja eine neue Time-Capsule rausgekommen.
Jetzt überlegst du dir, die gibt's zu kaufen?
Ja.
Dein altes Herr geht mal durch.
Die hat ja nach 18 Monaten...
Ja, die geht raus, dann hab ich zwei Terabyte, aber das entscheidende Feature, was ich gelesen habe, keine Ahnung ob's stimmt, aber man greift ja nach jedem Strohhalm. Sie haben gesagt, dass sie den Speed, den Time Machine Backup Speed erhöht haben um 60% Performance, ist ihre Aussage. Ob das nun stimmt, sagen wir dahingestellt. Ich frage mich auch, wie sie das sozusagen bewerkstelligen. Könnte man natürlich da einige Optimierungen vorstellen, insbesondere ist das Problem, dass du natürlich Heavy Fall System Performance da hast. Also da ist einfach viel hin und her, die ganze Latenz, da lässt sich eine ganze Menge wahrscheinlich allein schon durch ein Prozessor-Upgrade drehen. Bisher liefen ja alle Airpodexpresser auf NetBSD. Jetzt können sie einerseits einfach einen schnelleren Prozessor genommen haben, was ich für am wahrscheinlichsten halte, weil das Design ist ja nun nicht gerade das neueste. Dass das Ding halt einfach schneller ist und damit eben auch bei Time Machine einfach besser performt.
Und dass es jetzt Mac OS fährt.
Genau, wir haben ja einfach eine OS-Variante.
Naja, ich meine, das sind mittlerweile die einzigen Produkte, die nicht Mac OS fahren, außer die kleinen iPods.
Du meinst demnächst gibt es eine Time Machine Jailbreak?
Ob das nun so aufgebaut ist wie iPhone OS oder ob das eher so aufgebaut ist wie Mac OS, das sei mal dahingestellt. Aber im Prinzip könnten sie das tun. So. Es wird eh Zeit für Server im Heim, wie ich schon immer sagte und wie sie jetzt endlich wohl auch mir zugehört haben.
Darum hast du jetzt einen Windows-Home-Server gekauft.
Aber so eine Time Capsule ist doch verdammt scheiße teuer.
Es ist ein Produkt, was ein Problem sehr elegant löst. Und das Wert ist einem das, was es anbringt.
Also die 1 TB Version kostet 250, richtig?
Kann sein.
Und die 2 TB Version kostet 450, also 200 Euro mehr. Das heißt, 200 Euro mehr für 1 TB mehr Speicher. Dabei kostet eine 1 TB Platte irgendwie 60 Euro.
Sind da 2 Platten drin oder nur eine?
Eine.
Das ist ja sowieso auch mal so ein...
Die sind auch viel zu teuer, die 2 TB Platten.
Also ich würde ja erstmal überhaupt anfangen zu überlegen, wenn da 2 Platten drin wären, damit man irgendwie so ein bisschen mürren kann oder irgendwie so...
Zum Beispiel auch so was, ja.
Naja, du kannst ja...
Ein Backup ist ja sowieso Quatsch. Also wenn, dann brauchst du ja 2.
Du kannst extern ja nochmal eine andere anschließen, ja.
Ein Time Capsule.
Aber mürren kannst du dann trotzdem nicht. Mit der externen.
Nee, das ist alles... Das ist alles, ja.
Das hatten wir aber glaube ich schon mal, oder? Eigentlich, was richtig rauskommen muss, ist, dass die Eier legende Rollen mich da. Also eine Time Capsule mit Audio-Ausgang, damit man das so benutzen kann wie eine AirPod Express. Dann natürlich USB für den Drucker. Dann USB für weitere Festplatten. Dann irgendwie Storch für deine Musik, dass du halt die Musik gleich da drauf lassen kannst und auch von dort über den Ausgang abspielen kannst oder von dort die auf deinen iTunes holen kannst. Also dass der gleich die ganze Musik hat. Also dass er auch gleich Musik-Server wird fürs ganze iTunes-Zeugs. Und Video. Ja, das ist eigentlich genau. Also alle Produkte, die die haben, was mit irgendwie, also was kein Mac ist, sollten immer in eins zusammenführen. Und dann irgendwie Apple TV Super Express Time-Capsule-Dings nennen. Gibt's doch. Und wie heißt es?
Mac Mini.
Naja, ist die Frage.
Was sind denn Mac Mini jetzt zwei Packungen?
Mac Mini Server meinst du?
Mac Mini Server oder zwei Packungen?
Die schaffen es halt so super von einem Thema zu nichts.
Ja, also der Mac Mini Server ist ein bemerkenswertes Produkt, weil sie sich einmal getraut haben, einfach die CD wegzulassen, was einfach mal sinnvoll ist. Andererseits, kriegst du jetzt für 999 Dollar, kriegst du ein Mac Mini mit Mac OS X Server. Vor einem Jahr hat Mac OS X Server 999 Dollar gekostet. Ohne Mac Mini und so weiter.
Ja, aber Mac, also ich glaube das OS X Server, das will gar keiner haben.
Das ist die Frage, wie sie das...
Das Ding hat eine Seriennummer und so. Also das ist schon noch eine andere Nummer, als das normal ist.
Ja, ist schon klar, aber braucht man wirklich ein OS X Server?
Das ist die nächste Frage. Also ich hab das Produkt seit längerem nicht mehr verfolgen können. Ich weiß nicht, was sich jetzt mit Snow Labutter getan hat. Einiges. Hast du da einen Plan?
Ja, wir haben das gerade bei Artcom in der Evaluierung als Ersatz für die schönen Oracle-Produkte.
Du musst sagen, bei uns in der Firma.
Bei uns in der Firma, ja.
Genau.
Das muss man auch in andere Firmen einladen, wie Fexter zum Beispiel oder...
Genau. Und wir haben da eben so Oracle-Zeug für Collaboration-Suite und so. Das ist alles ganz scheußlich. Und jetzt wird halt gerade geguckt, ob wir nicht Mac OS X Server nehmen können. Und da hat sich... Also ich fahre in der Uni, da hatte ich irgendwie auch schon jetzt 10.5 Server und von 10.5 Server zu 10.6 Server hat sich wieder irgendwie ganz schön quantensprungmäßig einiges getan. Also Kalender Server, Wikiserver und dieser ganze Kram, der war halt in 10.5 noch eigentlich überhaupt nicht benutztbar.
Also so eine 1.0, so eine Apple Server 1.0.
Ja, so irgendwie nette Ansätze, aber wenn du das dann wirklich anfängst zu benutzen, denkst du dir irgendwie, hier geht ja gar nichts eigentlich.
Ja, das kenne ich, diesen Effekt.
So und da haben sie jetzt schon echt wieder ordentlich zugelegt. Ich kann auch nicht endgültig sagen, ob es jetzt wirklich schon taugt, aber auf jeden Fall bei 10.5 Server, beim Kalender, konntest du zum Beispiel einfach nicht in deinem iCal Gruppenkalender editieren, sondern das konntest du nur im Web machen. Aber deinen eigenen Kalender konntest du nicht im Web editieren, sondern nur im iCal. Und dann konntest du nicht irgendwie Gruppenkalender subscribieren und dann musstest du im iCal den Webkalender freigeben und so ganz komische Hürden machen halt einfach dran. Und die Integration mit iPhone, Sync und so weiter, das war alles nicht da. Und das haben sie jetzt bei 10.6 Server schon um einiges verbessert. Und sowieso, ihre GUI updaten sie ja auch jedes Mal. Also das Mac OS 10 Server wird schon von Version zu Version besser. Aber ehrlich gesagt, so zum Hosten benutze ich das auch nicht. Also in der Uni habe ich einen XServe im Rack mit 10.5 Server. Benutze ich eigentlich nur als Storage-Maschine und fürs LDAP. So, das ist das Einzige, was ich so richtig produktiv bin.
Dabei sind ja ein paar ganz interessante Tools dran, gerade für die Unis. Hast du dir mal diesen Podcast-Producer angeschaut?
Also ich hab wirklich nur diese Collaboration-Features bisher angeschaut, eben ums in der Firma oder in der Uni zu benutzen. Viel Kalenderkram. So, und bei 10.6 habe ich mir jetzt auch sozusagen für die Uni wieder eine Version schon bestellt. Mal gucken, ob das dann taubt. Aber wie gesagt, so diese Features, wenn man halt nicht die Kalender subskribieren kann, dann ist halt der Webkalender zwar gut und schön, aber so eine Geschichten halt.
Also dieser Podcast-Producer, er hat den auch noch nicht getestet. Er verspricht ja so ein bisschen Automatisierung von Podcast-Produktionen, insbesondere gerade für so Unis. Also wenn du halt Vorträge aufnimmst und so weiter, um dann einfach schnell von der aufgezeichneten Version zu einem geposteten Video in verschiedenen Formaten zu kommen. Fände ich mal ganz interessant, wenn du das mal anschaust. Also ich lieb Eugel so ein bisschen, damit auch mal so ein Mac OS-Tent-Server so in die eigene Infrastruktur mit reinzubringen, aber auch mir ist noch nicht so ganz klar, so eine Musiklösung wäre einfach so eine geile Killer-Up. Da würde man sagen, ah klar, allein schon wegen Musik, dass man einfach mal ein Media-Server hat und so. Warum bauen sie hier kein Media-Server ein? Das ist mir wirklich ein Rätsel. Da könnten sie auch mit ihrem ganzen DRM-Klimbim. Ich meine, dann agiert ihr halt wie ein normaler Client, hat bloß die Möglichkeit auch von außen bedient und verwaltet zu werden. Meinetwegen auch über das Web, wenn es unbedingt sein muss, wenn sie keine eigene Applikation für machen wollen. Sie können das ja auch in ihr bloated iTunes mit reinbauen. Das macht dann irgendwie auch nichts mehr aus, warum die Arbeit mehr runterladen muss. Aber das ist doch einfach so scheiße naheliegend. Gerade so dieses Problem, wenn du mit diesen AirPod Expressen und iTunes arbeitest, dann spielt halt irgendjemand was ab. So in deiner Familie, so das läuft, dann willst du das nicht mehr hören, dann ist die Person irgendwie aus dem Haus raus und der Rechner ist gelockt. Jetzt musst du da sozusagen den Rechner hacken und das iTunes abschießen oder einfach den Laptop zuklappen, wenn du die Möglichkeit hast oder Strom abziehen, damit es wieder Ruhe ist. Das kann doch nicht wahr sein. Wo bleibt da einfach mal der korrekte Ansatz, dass man sagen kann, hier gibt es mehrere User, die alle irgendwie was ein- und ausschalten dürfen oder man hat dann die entsprechende Oberfläche auf seinem fucking iPhone?
Kann aber auch sein, dass die mehr drauf abzielen über den, wie soll man sagen, den kurzen Gebrauch der Musik. Vielleicht wollen die gar nicht, dass so die dicken Sammler kommen, die alles aufheben, sondern die wollen halt, dass du heute Britney hörst und morgen schon Lady Gaga oder wie die alle heißen. Und dich eigentlich gar nicht mehr kümmerst um deinen alten Scheiß.
Aber mit diesem Homesharing kannst du doch problemlos auf diesen Server mit draufsünden. Jetzt haben sie doch im Prinzip alles da.
Ja, eigentlich schon.
Den nimmst du da mit rein und jeder, der einen eigenen iTunes-Account hat auf seinem Rechner, der mit seinem Laptop was gekauft hat, stellt das so ein, dass es auf diesen Server gleich automatisch mit draufsüngt. Und da können dann aber auch alle auswählen und sagen, das soll jetzt hier und hier und hier und hier an dem und dem Raum zu hören sein. Fertig ist das Heim-Audiosystem. Dafür zahlen manche Leute viel Geld, um sich irgendeinen Bose oder Löwe oder wenn ihr nicht alles noch solche Lösungen baut. Ja, ist dieses andere Teil so nahe?
Ist das nicht auch von Logitech?
Ich weiß es gerade nicht. Es gibt also verschiedene Anbieter, die versuchen eben dieses Problem da zu tacklen und ja.
Aber ich zum Beispiel Mac Mini Server jetzt nochmal irgendwie überlege, jetzt hast du dann zwei Platten drin. Okay, dann machst du mit deinem Disk utility so einen HFS plus Mürrer, damit er halt irgendwie und so weiter und so fort und dann ist halt mal dein HFS plus kaputt. Dann sitzt du da...
Der Mürrer ist kaputt. Genau, da fehlt auf beiden Platten Teil.
Ja und vor allen Dingen mit zwei Terabyte Platten, das Resilvering und so, das dauert dann ein gefühlter Jahr.
Nee, da sind dann noch zweieinhalb Zoll Platten drin.
Also ich hatte ja bei uns in der Firma, wie war das mal? Bei uns in der Firma?
Bei uns in der Firma.
Also ich hab ja eine Linux Workstation. Bei mir um, oft mal Loche. Habe ich gerne eine Linux Workstation unterm Tisch bekommen, so mit Debian. Und da ist halt so ein DM RAID Software Fubar Kram drauf und das ist halt kaputt gegangen. Und das hat dann tatsächlich einen halben Tag gedauert zu resilvern, wie man so schön sagt. Und dann habe ich das abgebrochen und einen FreeBSD mit ZFS installiert. Also auf dem Mac Mini würde ich glaube ich auch gar nicht OS X Server fahren wollen.
Du meinst du nimmst einen Mac Mini, man kauft sich einen... Ja, natürlich, klar. Man kauft sich diesen scheiß Mac Mini, wirft das OS X Server weg und installiert da einen FreeBSD drauf. Warum ich auf die Idee noch nicht gekommen? Aber da hat man nur ein halbes... Um einen performanten Server zu haben.
Eigentlich Format.
Ja, ok, das kleine Format ist natürlich toll, aber... Da kann man doch wirklich irgendeinen PC von einer Stange nehmen, der 200 Euro kostet.
Ein PC von einer Stange? Mach's!
Also du kannst dir...
Womöglich noch mit das Kettenlaufwerk.
Es gibt da wirklich interessante Sachen, die so ähnlich aussehen wie der Drobo mittlerweile, wo du wirklich so Platten von vorne reinschieben kannst und wo ein PC mit drin ist. Jaja klar, aber da läuft ja nicht die richtige Software drauf.
Gibt's da nicht dieses FriNAS oder was heißt? Da ist doch die richtige Software.
Läuft die auf FreeBSD?
Ja, das heißt der FriNAS. Und hat Zeltelfest inzwischen.
Dann haben die auch Time Machine Support.
Das wird mit dem NetAtalk ja dann eventuell kommen.
Das heißt, achso, okay, man könnte... Aber dieses FriNAS, kommt das mit NetAtalk?
Na ja, 204, also die Version von vorher.
Nein, ich meine, gehört zu FriNAS auch NetAtalk oder ist das nur Samba-Kram?
Weiß ich nicht. Ich mach mein Kram als Hause selber. Ich kenne diese Boxen nicht. Aber das ist ja dann auch nicht mehr schwer. Oder kommt man an die Boxen dann nicht mehr ran oder wie? Kann man da nichts machen. Müssen wir uns mal ganz genauer angucken.
Next. Na gut, wo wir schon bei den neuen Rechnern sind?
Aber noch kurz reingeschoben, der ZFS-Programmierer, der für Krypto zuständig ist, bei dem follow ich ja auch im Twitter, Darren Moffat oder so heißt er, der hat auch, als der Mac Mini Server rauskam, auch gleich überlegt, macht er sich da irgendwie ein Open Solaris drauf oder irgendwie ein FreeBSD. Also der fand den Rechner auch gleich schick. Der Formfaktor ist einfach cool.
Hier schreibt gerade einer im Chat, Windows-Home-Server haben auch Time Machine Support. Könnte man sich auch ein Windows-Home-Server kaufen.
Wie die haben Time Machine Support?
Das ist jetzt genauso gut wie der Mac, habe ich gehört.
Also langsam wird es eklig hier.
Unser Wave-Drucken-Problem hätte fast gelöst werden können. Weil ich verwende ja, vielleicht sollte man das auch mal erwähnen, ich verwende, um Wave zu benutzen, verwende ich nicht den Browser, sondern ich verwende ein Standalone-Programm namens WaveBoard. Habt ihr das auch schon mal angefasst? getwaveboard.com. Schreibt auch ein Deutscher, der wohl hier auch ein bisschen zuhört.
Du hast ziemlich aktiv auch in der entsprechenden Wave.
Genau. Und das ist eigentlich ein sehr schöner Ansatz, weil er im Prinzip nichts anderes macht, als da erstmal mit WebKit den eigentlichen Google-Wave-Content einfach ins Fenster zu drücken, wie das eben die anderen Browser auch machen. Aber dann Schritt für Schritt über die Wave-ARP bestimmte Dinge macht. Also er ist dann in der Lage, wie viele Waves haben sich geändert, Batch-Updates.
Das macht er glaube ich nicht per ARP, sondern da hängt er sich einfach ein paar Hooks ins JavaScript rein.
Gut, wie er es auch immer macht, sein Ziel ist, das Ganze in das OS besser einzubetten und er sprach auch davon, das über die ARP zu machen. Das kann man sicherlich auch noch mal ein bisschen genauer hinterfragen. Ich habe jetzt nur so mitgearbeitet, das ist einfach die Alternative zu, sich so eine Web-App mit Fluid zu machen. Geht das nicht mittlerweile auch mit Safari?
Das war irgendwann mal eine Beta-Base, die wir mal drin hatten. Haben sie da rausgeschmissen.
Haben sie da rausgeschmissen.
Ja, mit Fluid, alles gestieft.
Seitdem der wieder da ist.
Es gab wahrscheinlich auch ein Patent loss.
Ja, genau. Der war krank und kommen die voll geilen Features alle hoch. Jetzt ist er wieder da und alles gestieft.
Na geil, na super. Toll, ich will meinen Tim Cook wieder haben. Pflaume. Na weiß der Geier, was er für uns hat. Auf jeden Fall dieses Waveboard ist sehr schön. Kann ich nur empfehlen. Und jetzt rausstehe ich gerade vor meiner Nase die Ankündigung eines Updates. Aber das Update lädt runter und meint Fehler beim Extrahieren des Archivs.
Bei mir hat es sich installiert. 07? Wirklich?
Vielleicht sollte ich mein WAVE-Board nochmal neu starten. Da ist jetzt auch ein Druckenbefehl drin. Vielleicht kriegen wir unsere Wave noch gedruckt. Aber ich kriege es derzeit noch nicht mal geupdatet. Das wäre schon mal ganz hilfreich.
Ich habe festgestellt, dass man bei diesem Sparkle, Sparkle heißt das doch, oder? Dass die in letzter Zeit gerne dazu neigt, Programme zu zerschießen. Und dass die darum nicht klappen. Also, dass man entweder das Download nicht klappt, oder?
Nein, klappt's.
Finden euch damit ab!
Nein, ganz ehrlich Max, damit finden wir uns nicht ab. Also, so können sie uns nicht kommen.
Die Druckfunktion ist hier der totale Hammer hier.
Na, wieso, was macht sie denn?
Ich gucke gerade mal.
Sie druckt den Inhalt des ganzen Bildschirms, oder was?
Ich weiß nicht, was sie druckt, aber...
Das ist nicht das, was man haben will.
Das ist sicher nicht das, was man haben will.
Mal gucken, ich ducke auch mal. Aber immerhin, es gibt immerhin schon mal ein Kommando, was druckt, dann kann man darüber reden, dass es noch besser ist als vorher.
Irgendwann könnte es vielleicht sogar durchdrucken, was man will.
Man müsste im Prinzip den Inhalt dieser Wave nehmen und die in so eine Seite neu reinrennen für das Drucken. Jetzt gucke ich mal, was er macht.
Okay, also wir haben jetzt Window 7 gelogen. Was kommt als Nächstes?
Das hilft uns jetzt in der Tat nicht weiter.
Hat jemand einen Parallelport-Kabel dabei?
Die nächsten Themenkarten sind die anderen Rechner, die alle rausgekommen sind. Wir haben ja irgendwie ein Schild.
Hat schon jemand so eine Magic Mouse?
Nee, kann man ja auch nicht kaufen.
Ich glaube, keiner hat überhaupt irgendwas. Es ist von 1 bis 2 bis 3 Tagen Lieferzeit gewesen.
Ich glaube, ich fahre nachher noch mal.
Hier zum Apple Center.
Findest du das Wichtigste?
Nein, aber das ist ja der kleine Einstieg erst mal mit Warmwerden für die neuen Sachen. Und die Magic Mouse, die ist ja... Also ich hab ja überhaupt eigentlich so eine Mighty Mouse. Wer hat hier ja gesagt...
Ich, ich, ich, ich.
Ich find's eigentlich schlecht. Also der Ball wird tatsächlich sehr schnell dreckig, aber sonst ist die eigentlich ganz okay.
Die ist total cool, weil dieses Feedback, was eigentlich aus dem Lautsprecher kommt, aber man trotzdem denkt, dass es irgendwie so vibriert auf dem Finger, also dass die Kugel so ruckler macht, das total cool funktioniert. Aber sie wird halt wirklich, wenn sie erstmal dreckig geworden ist, dann wird's schwierig, sie wieder sauber zu kriegen.
Diese Seiten-Tasten haben auch nie wirklich funktioniert.
Die hab ich eh gleich abgeschaltet. Aber sonst ist die total...
Diese Mighty Mouse, die können sie auch eigentlich auch im Erotikmarkt verkaufen, oder?
Ich glaube, das war eigentlich so ihr Hauptpunkt. Das sieht so ein bisschen aus wie...
Direkt bei Beate Use aus dem Regal gezogen.
Ich glaube, das ist der einzige Grund, warum ich mir eine gekauft habe.
Die Maus ist total cool, aber wenn der Pin da erst mal... wenn der erst mal dreckig ist, dann geht's im meisten nur noch in die eine Richtung, aber nicht mehr in die andere, das ist voll cool. Das ist total nervig. Und diesen Zustand hat meine Maus jetzt immer öfter.
Kannst du die nicht einfach so in so eine Tunke einlegen?
Ich hab einmal komplett ausgebaut, alles sauber gemacht, aber es kam relativ schnell wieder.
Also es gibt da so diesen Trick, dass man mit Tesafilm so irgendwie unten drunter gehen kann.
Das ist ja wie früher bei den Kugel-Mäusen.
Das ist ja eine Kugel-Maus quasi.
Das ist genau das gleiche Prinzip nur auf der Oberseite.
Dass man die Kugel noch direkt vertricken kann und nicht warten muss, dass es sich ganz über den Tisch einsammelt.
Was ich mache, ich hole immer die Nadel aus meinem Schweizer Taschmesser raus und fahre so einmal um die Kugel drum rum, damit sich da alles löst.
Das war früher eine meiner Haupttätigkeiten als Systemadministrator.
Mäuse reinigen. Ja, ich bin einmal die Woche rumgegangen und habe diese Idee ausgenommen. Bei Pixelpark können wir immer ausgehen, nicht merke mal. Genau, sauber gemacht. Ich wollte eigentlich eine neue. Nee, nee, die ist jetzt sauber. Jedenfalls, diese neue Magic Mouse, was ich erst mal wissen wollte, die hat weiterhin einen physikalischen Klick. Den Klick wird nicht über den Touch erkannt. Sonst kann man seinen Finger nicht parken da drauf. Dann muss man den immer so schwebend halten, dann kriegt man einen Krampf im Arm.
Nee, das kriegen die schon.
Also der Klick ist physikalisch weiter.
So habe ich das auch verstanden.
Das wäre nämlich schon wichtig. Und dann, wenn man dann nämlich keinen, wie heißt das Ding genannt, die Kugel, wenn man die nicht mehr hat und nicht mehr sauber machen muss, ich meine, das ist doch perfekt.
Das wird sich zeigen, ob das so perfekt ist. Ich bin ehrlich gesagt ein bisschen enttäuscht. Ich will ja immer noch das andere Produkt haben. Ich will überhaupt keine Mouse. Ich will das, was ich hier in meinem Laptop habe, hätte ich gerne als einzelnes Ding. Eine Tastatur, mit einem Trackpad darunter und einer Handablage.
Und da liegt ja auch die Mouse einfach unter die Tastatur.
Ja, aber wenn ich jetzt in meinem Sessel sitze und der Rechner steht irgendwie auf dem Tisch und ich will dann einfach mal mit einem Meter Entfernung, schön wireless, arbeiten mit dem Computer, wo soll ich dann bitte die Mouse hinlegen? Jetzt soll ich mit meiner Mouse auf den Bein rumfahren? Das ist doch krank. Warum nicht einfach so ein Trackpad, mit dem man auch alles machen kann?
Das stimmt.
Einfach ein Trackpad und eine Tastatur in einem Teil schön in Alu. Das kann man sich irgendwie auch schön in seine Tasche reinstecken. Das ist schön flach. Das funktioniert alles, das haben sie alles schon. Da müssen sie nichts Neues erfinden. Das müssen sie einfach nur ausliefern. Und dann hat man das einfach.
Kauft ihr doch so ein schön EEPC-Keyboard.
Nehme mal ehrlich, wozu eine Mouse? Ich verstehe, dass manchmal eine Mouse eine bessere Sache ist. Ich finde es auch okay, dass sie die Mouse verbessert haben. Ich will trotzdem meine Tastatur mit Trackpad haben.
Das wäre Netzwerk.
Ich hoffe nicht.
Das wäre Dufte. Also nicht Netzwerk werden, sondern Mouse mit Trackpad.
Also ich kriege noch Updates im Chat. Von daher habe ich noch...
Also eigentlich so ein MacBook-Unterteil hier so. Mit einem großen Glas Trackpad unten drin.
Genau.
Das wäre super.
Könnte auch noch das alte Trackpad sein.
Nein, nein, nein.
Eigentlich könnten sie dann gleich eine Glasscheibe rausbringen mit Soft-Keyboard und voll Multitouch und allem. So, dann brauchst du aber hier...
Das Tablett.
Naja, echt mal so mit physischen Tasten und so.
Wie auch immer. Also ich denke, es ist gut, dass sie das machen und dass sie jetzt keine mechanischen Teile mehr drin haben außer dem Klick. Weil ich glaube, den haben sie bisher immer noch so lange funktionieren lassen.
Könnte der nicht auch irgendwie mit Piezo oder irgendwie sowas sein?
Mit dem Piezo machen sie den Ton dafür, dass du glaubst, es klickt, aber es klickt gar nicht, sondern das Ding macht nur einen Ton.
Ich guck mal nachher.
Also machen sie das doch derzeit bei dieser Multi-Maus, oder?
Die Kugel ja, die simuliert jede Bewegung mit einem so einem Klick aus diesem Lautfeld.
Nein, die klickt nicht, sondern die sagt Klick.
Das ist wie dein iPhone. Moment mal.
Da klickt nichts, ich hab's auseinandergenommen. Innen drin ist nichts weiter als glatte Räder.
Also hier, das klickt schon. Ja, das ja auch im Aus. Aber das hier, das macht keiner.
Dieses Hoch-Runter.
Genau, außer du hast Strom da und dann kommt dein Klicker aus dem Lautsprecher. Ja, mit Kopfhörer aufhörst du's eh nicht.
Das ist jetzt genau die Position, was diese Maus auch als Erotik-Element wiegt. Trust me, it works.
Ja, das brauchen wir jetzt nicht zu übertreiben.
Gib mir mal lieber noch so einen Soft-Kick. Ich bin auch ein großer Soft-Kick-Freund.
So, okay, das heißt... Ich nicht?
Na, warte, ihr macht ihr mal weiter.
Ich hab hier durftiges Netz gerade.
Gib mir mal eine bessere Fehlerbeschreibung. Kann ich dir vielleicht auch helfen? Genau, probier's mal so.
So, ich hab hier so eine Magic Mouse, wir hatten einen Mac Mini und Mac Mini Server.
Das gibt's auch nicht, oder? Doch. Neue Apple Remote! Was?
Moment, es gibt neue Mac Minis.
Neue Apple Remote.
Es gibt neue Mac Minis.
Mac Mini Server.
Nee, wir haben nur den Server gesprochen. Ja, sind billiger geworden. 50 Euro immerhin. Und größere Platte, glaube ich. Ansonsten hat sich nicht viel geändert. Das heißt, wir haben auch immer noch die beiden Bildschirme. Wir haben immer noch den alten und den neuen, den Mini DisplayPort.
Du kannst zwei Monitore dran anschließen.
Genau, das finde ich cool. Wobei man ja theoretisch auch über den Mini DisplayPort sowieso zwei anschließen könnte, laut Spezifikation.
Könnte.
Genau, oder mehrere, mehr sogar noch als zwei. Ich weiß jetzt gerade gar nicht, aber zwei auf jeden Fall. Aber das wird wohl dann noch kommen. Immerhin verbessert sich das Ganze, ja. Und naja, jetzt müssen wir auf jeden Fall mal die iMacs erwähnen, denke ich. Ja, ich würde sagen...
Also ich will einen haben.
Strike, ich hab schon einen bestellt.
Und welchen jetzt?
Wer hätte das geahnt?
Das mit dem Quantensprung.
Genau, das mit dem Quantensprung.
Da würdest du auch noch kurz drauf eingehen vielleicht.
Auf den Quantensprung? Dass ein Quantensprung kein Quantensprung ist, sozusagen?
Naja, aber der i5 oder i7 an sich ist ja erst mal ein Quantensprung.
Also, fassen wir mal kurz zusammen, wissen wir wahrscheinlich sowieso schon alle, aber damit wissen wir darüber reden. Es gibt neue iMacs und die sind total toll. Die haben nämlich einen LED-Bildschirm. Der ist gebaut nach dieser IPS-Technologie, wo ich leider noch nicht ausreichend nachgeschaut habe, was es ist, aber das bedeutet wohl vor allem ein besserer Seiteneinblick.
Ich hab's mir durchgelesen und hab's wieder vergessen. Das ist eine relativ alte Technologie, die war früher nur, die haben irgendwie die Kristalle wurden nicht nur vertikal ausgerichtet, sondern auch noch in verschiedenen Winkel. Das hat bloß zu einer relativ langen Schaltzeit geführt, weswegen es nicht so populär war. Aber jetzt gibt's seit diesem Jahr von, ich weiß nicht mehr wem, neue Displays damit, die wohl auch auf höhere Geschwindigkeiten kommen.
In-plane-Switching heißt das?
Genau.
Ich guck gleich in der englischen Wikipedia, weil in Deutschland ist das bestimmt nie relevant. Ja, das ist wirklich echt vorbei. Ich werd auch echt nicht mehr auf die linken. Bla, bla, bla, white viewing angle und so weiter. Okay, bis wir sie jetzt mal durchlesen. Falscher Zeitpunkt. Aber auf jeden Fall, die Bildschirme sehen ganz cool aus. Sind halt jetzt auch alles LED-beleuchtete, also Hinterruhbeleuchtete.
LED-beleuchtete. Flacher.
Vor allem sind die halt größer. Also anstatt den 24 Zoll haben sie es jetzt auf 27 erhöht. Wobei man dazu sagen muss, die schummeln ein bisschen, weil es ist kein 16 zu 10 Bildschirm, so wie vorher. Sondern jetzt haben sie es noch ein bisschen mehr in die Breite gezogen. Es ist ein 16 zu 9 Bildschirm. Nee, breiter.
Breiter.
16 zu 10 ist das hier und zu 9 ist nur noch bis hier.
Also 140 Pixel weniger als beim 30 Zoll. Aber sie haben fast dieselbe Auflösung wie ein 30 Zoll Bildschirm. Und vor allem der 27 Zoll iMac kostet 100 Dollar mehr als der 30 Zoll Bildschirm. Und das coole ist, dass du jetzt über den Mini Display Port auch das Ganze als Bildschirm machen kannst. Was sie aber nicht sagen, ist, wie genau das funktionieren soll.
Aber es steht da, dass man es machen kann.
Ja, aber was heißt das? Muss man dann den iMac dafür ausschalten und dann ist er nur Bildschirm? Und wie schaltet man ihn dann den Bildschirm ein, ohne den iMac einzuschalten? Oder kann man wirklich einen Mac Mini daneben stellen, den als Monitor betreiben, den iMac auch laufen lassen, ihn auch als für den iMac machen und dann zwischen den beiden Bildschirmen hin und her schalten? Aber wenn ja, wie?
Mit einem Schalter, mit einem Swipe über die Magic Mouse. Über den Bildschirm.
Multi-Touch-Bildschirm, endlich.
Jetzt weiß das Tablett, was benutzen sie.
Ist das der Grund, warum die den 30 Zoller-Bildschirm nicht updaten? Weil man kauft jetzt einfach einen iMac?
Ich könnte mir vorstellen, als gehst du so draufhauen, ganz toll finden. Und dann wechselt das Bild.
Du hast ja einen bestellt jetzt.
Also ich hab jetzt gerade gemutmaßt, dass der 24 Zoller würde dann auch von alleine angehen, wenn man den Rechner anschaltet.
Das kann auch durchaus sein.
Das würde dann aber bedeuten, du kannst ihn zwar als Bildschirm für einen anderen Rechner benutzen, aber dann ist der iMac aus.
Wir werden es sehen.
Cooler wäre es natürlich, wenn du dann hin und her schalten könntest, weil du willst ja nicht immer deinen iMac runterfahren. Weil dann ist ja auch Quatsch. Warum solltest du den dann? Dann bist du gezwungen, deinen Computer nicht weiter zu betreiben. Ich dachte schon, man hätte einen Bildschirm für einen anderen Rechner, so Mac Pro, dann hast du einen 27 Zoll Bildschirm und den iMac benutzt du sozusagen als Background-Server oder so.
Ja, oder als, du kannst ja hier, es gibt ja immer mehr Sachen, die man bei so Mac Pro Software auch distributet. Hier Final Cut, Video Rendering oder GCC compiling und so. Wenn du dann einfach deinen Mac Pro anschließt, der iMac ist auch noch da und gibt seine Chores zu mit compiling. So nichts anderem sozusagen, ja.
Ich kriege keine Adressen mehr. Entweder ist der MDRCP kaputt oder...
Du sollst eh nicht die ganze Zeit in den Bildschirm gucken.
Ich kann das ja, ich kann das ja gerade nicht erklären. Ich will jetzt aber auch nicht dran rumzippeln, um den Stream nicht zu gefährden. Ich kann dir aber meinen Netz sharen, wenn dir das weiterhilft. Oder vielleicht kann das mal jemand anders machen, damit ich mein Streaming nicht... Könnt ihr ihm nicht mal eure Verbindungen sharen, dass er Netz hat?
Ist das schon Blasphämie, wenn ich sage, diese Apple-Funkstationen sind alle total scheiße, wenn sie alle zwei Stunden abstürzen?
Das ist keine Blasphämie. Ich hab die gekauft vor anderthalb Jahren und wieder angefasst.
Nein, nein, nein, die ist nicht abgestürzt, die funktioniert. Was jetzt hier gerade nicht funktioniert, ist mir nicht klar. DRCP funktioniert nicht. Ja gut, aber DRCP macht eine Büchse da hinten.
Aber gib mir doch, also ich kann dir ja mal die IP sagen.
Wir müssen jetzt nicht über unser Studio-Setup, was auch wirklich funktioniert, reden. Das soll uns aber froh sein, solange wir hier noch senden.
Übrigens, wenn ich das hier gerade sehe, du hast noch eine 72er-IP, ne? Ist das als Local-Netz, oder wie? Ja. Ist glaube ich jetzt mittlerweile ja Public-IP. Doch.
Was?
Seit wann? Na, letztens wollte ich einen Host erreichen. Slide-Share oder so, aber ich IP hab nie.
Vielleicht 172 irgendwas, aber bestimmt nicht der Netzrahmen.
Das ist ja nur ein kleiner Bereich.
Also wenn er Public wäre, dann würde er den Apple bestimmt nicht im System-Administrationsinterface anpumpen.
Außerdem ist er seit Jahren Public. Also intern können sie nicht plötzlich Public machen.
Aber kann das sein, dass sie plötzlich vergeben werden?
Ja doch, machen sie.
Warum sollen sie...
Ich hab... 174er haben sie jetzt frei eben, stimmt. Sorry, alles zurück und überhaupt das Gegenteil.
Das machen wir mal in einem Netz auf jeden Fall. Ich kippe ja gar nicht.
iMacs.
So, es gibt einen Quad-Core iMac. Mit dem i5, Core i5 heißt das Teil.
Drei gibt's ja eigentlich, oder? Also drei verschiedene...
Das ist diese sparsame Variante von dieser Nehalem-Architektur.
Also der i5 ist, wenn ich das richtig verstanden habe, der Nachführer vom Core 2 Duo dann irgendwann mal.
Der wird dann sicherlich demnächst auch in einem MacBook in ihrer Nähe landen.
Also, Core 2 Duo, dann kam der Nehalem raus, der i7 hieß oder hieß das?
Nehalem ist die Architektur, ja.
Genau, und das haben die jetzt seit einem Jahr irgendwie gemacht. Nehalem, die Mac Pros haben ja den auch drin. Und jetzt hat Intel halt neue Versionen nachgelegt, die halt i5 heißen, so ein bisschen sich billiger anhören, aber nicht so wirklich billiger sind eigentlich. Und die sparen nochmal reichlich mehr Strom, also so richtig viel. Aber der i5 hat kein Hyper-Threading, weil der i7 hat nämlich Hyper-Threading. Du hast nicht wirklich eine komplett zusätzliche CPU, also so einen weiteren Core, sondern die haben ja so eine Pipeline da drin und wenn die gerade irgendwie was abarbeiten muss, was irgendwie zu lange dauert in irgendeinem bestimmten Bereich, Floating Point oder Integer Unit, oder die muss gerade irgendwie aufs RAM zufetchten oder so, und es dauert zu lange, dann switcht der mal kurz auf einen anderen Prozess um und arbeitet den ab. Also der kann so ganz billig hin und her schalten. Das gab es ganz früher beim Pentium auch schon, beim Pentium 4, und dann, weiß nicht, das war so fünf Prozent schneller oder so was, was ja auch nicht so wenig ist, aber irgendwie haben bei FreeBSD hieß es auch immer, naja, schalt's mal besser aus, weil irgendwie bei zwei Cores, also weil es wären ja dann zwei Cores, wenn du eine CPU hast, die so ein Hyper-Switching hat, dann ist die zusätzliche Arbeit, um alles irgendwie für zwei Cores irgendwie zu managen, mehr als was dieses Hyper-Switching wirklich an Ergebnis bringt. Also du solltest schon wenigstens zwei richtige Cores haben, wenn das einschaltet. Und deswegen hieß es immer, am besten ausschalten. Und außerdem waren die damals mit dem Multi-Switching und mit dem mehreren Cores vielleicht noch nicht so weit. So, inzwischen ist es aber so, dass auch hier laut Benchmarks und so, dass dieses Hyper-Switching schon eher so in Richtung 10 bis 20 Prozent Speed bringt, also es lohnt sich schon. Kommt natürlich auch immer auf die Programme an und so weiter und so fort. Aber jedenfalls der E5, der hat das erstmal nicht. Das heißt, das ist ein normaler Quadcore, der hat vier Cores und sonst nichts. Und die große Version von dem iMac, die hat aber diesen E7. Und der hat dieses Hyper-Switching, und zwar pro Core. Also heißt der hat vier richtige Cores. Und jeder von denen hat auch noch ein Hyper-Switching. Das heißt, man hat eigentlich acht. Also vier richtige und vier diese 10 bis 20 Prozent bringen.
Die Frage ist, was bringt das jetzt real? Du hast 180 Euro extra.
Also wir würde es auf jeden Fall empfehlen, weil du brauchst sowieso immer alles und hast ja auch bestellt. Aber diese 180 Euro, die zahlst du ja nicht nur auch für das Hyper-Switching, sondern auch dafür, dass du hast ja ein paar Megajuts mehr. Das sind ja anstatt 2,66 sind es ja glaube ich 2,8.
Ja, Basistakt. Und dann noch dieser Turbo-Boost-Kram.
Damit der Rechner noch schneller abstürzen kann jetzt.
Und ich würde mal sagen, wenn einer wirklich viel Speed braucht, und sowieso Leute, die sich das angucken, die wollen ja anscheinend richtig viel Speed haben, für die lohnt sich es auch schon durch diesen Megahertz-Aufschlag.
Ja gut, Speed ist immer relativ. Das muss man natürlich auch eine Software haben, die das dann auch rauskitzelt. In dem Fall ist das etwas, was wirklich nur bei Volllast, bei vielen Cores kommt. Das ist eigentlich meine Anwendung, weil mir geht es halt um Encode.
So der normale User sollte sich überlegen, ob er wirklich seinen Rechner so auslastet, dass er mehr als vier Cores beschäftigen kann.
Nein, auch wenn du es jetzt noch nicht kannst, kannst du es dann vielleicht nächstes Jahr, und wenn du dann nicht mitspielen kannst, weil du die kleinere Version gekauft hast, ist halt blöd.
Also ich denke, das 4-Core-Teil, das geht auch schon ganz ordentlich ab.
Denke ich auch. Man muss noch dazu sagen, was, wenn die Mac-Jungs, das war vorher glaube ich nur beim Mac Pro, dann gucken die Leute ja vielleicht nicht so richtig, was das so ist und so, dieses Nehalem. Aber im Gegensatz zum Core 2 Duo, da war es noch so, dass, wie soll man sagen, der Speicherkontroller, der war nicht auf der CPU mit drauf, sondern der war extern, sogenannte North Bridge. Und AMD hat das schon irgendwie vor ein paar Jahren eingeführt, da ist der Memory-Controller mit auf der CPU drauf und deswegen kann damit der CPU selbst viel schneller irgendwie, also der Bus, das ist übertragen von Memory, ist viel schneller, also es ist alles viel flotter.
Zweieinhalb Mal so schnell RAM zugeführt.
Genau, das ist dieser, glaube ich, Hyper Transport nannt man das bei AMD, kann das sein?
Das kann sein, das weiß ich gerade nicht.
Und das ist das, was Intel ein bisschen hinterher war und was sie dann mit diesem NeHLM auch eingeführt haben. Das heißt, die Mega- oder Gigahertz-Zahlen inzwischen sind ja relativ gleich, also sind ja auch wieder nur bei 2,8 Gigahertz und 2,6. Ist jetzt alles nicht so doll schneller. Aber deren Memory-Zugriff ist halt um ein Vielfaches besser.
Das könnte eine Menge ausmachen bei speicherintensiven Prozessen.
Ja, das ist ja alles heute speicherintensiv. Das ist ja eigentlich der Haupt-Limiting-Faktor aus heute, wie schnell dein RAM ist.
Das stimmt.
Jedenfalls bei diesen Intels ist jetzt auch über diesen Ausbridge irgendwie das weggefallen. Und da ist der Memory-Controller jetzt auch mit auf der CPU drauf. Und das ist das, was den großen Speed-Gain bringt.
Wie viel Speicher hast du genommen?
Was für ein Speicher meinst du jetzt?
RAM.
Vollausbau ist ja nicht teuer. 8 GB reicht mir völlig.
Vier mal zwei.
Wahrscheinlich, ja.
Kleine 8 GB-Variante.
Weil die 4 GB-Module sind ja noch so Schweine teuer.
Ich hab mich noch nicht final entschieden für die Konfiguration, muss ich auch nicht. Doch, ich hab bestellt. Ich weiß bloß, dass da mehrere Konfigurationen ohnehin bestellt sind. Da das ja sowieso noch bis November dauert.
Kannst du auch noch umswitchen vorher.
Ich kann mir dann einen auswählen, ich kriege den ersten. Ja, das ist schön, wenn man ein gutes Verhältnis zu seinem Händler hat. Aber ich finde einfach, dieser iMac ist wirklich super konsequent. Schön finde ich auch, dass man den jetzt wieder mit so einem VESA-Mount ausstatten kann und kannst für 29 Euro so einen Halterungsadapter kaufen. Da machst du wohl den Fuß ab und dafür diese Halterung ran. Dann kannst du das Teil halt einfach so an den Wand hängen.
Ging das bei dem Letzten nicht?
Das hatten sie mal wieder so einlassen und jetzt haben sie es wieder eingeführt. Und das ist natürlich wirklich geil, dass du wirklich so ein klares, kristallines LED-Bildschirmchen hast, wo dann auch noch ein Computer drin ist. Das ist schon ein richtiger Fernseher, Großfernseher-Ersatz.
Na ja, physikalisch verglichen ist der aber noch ein bisschen kleiner als der 30-Zoll-Bildschirm, oder?
Na gut, 27 Zoll reicht für viele Leute aus, um Fernsehen zu gucken. Das ist nicht so, dass man da jetzt keinen Fernsehen drauf gucken könnte. Wenn du jetzt unbedingt einen 50 oder 60 Zoller brauchst, ok, alles klar. Dann musst du halt auf eine andere Technologie setzen.
Es ist kein großer Fernseher, es ist ein kleiner Fernseher.
Der hat einen Feature, was die anderen Fernseher nicht haben. Dann kannst du den Fernseher halt kaufen ohne Fernsehen. Das Schlimmste an einem Fernseher ist für mich irgendwie, dass die halt mit diesen Fernsehtunern kommen, sondern irgendwie dazu verführt wirst, vielleicht Fernsehen zu gucken.
Das will ich nicht.
Dafür braucht man nur das Antennenkabel nicht reinstecken. Das funktioniert sehr gut. Das hat bei mir bisher mal hervorragend geklappt. Einfach keine Antenne anschließen.
Weil DVB-T so scheiße ist, dass es ohne Antenne gar nicht mehr funktioniert?
Ich weiß gar nicht, ob mein Fernseher DVB-T hat, um ehrlich zu sein.
Wenn einmal bei Pirate Races so ein HD-Movie runtergelandet ist, kommt damit Fernsehen nicht mehr klar. Bei jedem Szenenwechsel, wenn du erst mal kurz noch diese ganze Blog-Soße auf dem Bildschirm siehst, das geht nicht.
DVB-T ist nicht zu vertragen. Das wird vielleicht mal wieder interessant, wenn sie dann DVB-T2 am Start haben.
Wenn sie ihre Keyframes am nächsten Mal immer auf den Szenenwechsel legen würden. Aber nee, ist immer mittendrin, irgendwo. Und wenn eine volle Action-Szene kommt, dann ist das eine Blog-Soße.
Die sind mit 2-3 Megabits höchstens pro Kanal.
Das ist voll viel. Früher diese 700 MB-Movies, die da gerippsert haben, die hatten irgendwie 800 Kilobits als Encoding-Rate. Das heißt, die haben das Dreifache davon.
Das ist doch noch ein Pick-2, was die da haben.
Der Chat korrigiert mich. Es gab wohl auch beim 24 Zoll-i-Megabit auch ein Weser-Mond-Kit. Jetzt nur für den 27 Zoll.
Wie bei iTunes sagen auch, wir würden ja voll oft, also in den Reviews, wie sagt man?
Kommentare?
Ja, vielleicht in Englisch. Jedenfalls, die sagen auch, wir würden ja oft irgendwie keine Ahnung haben und das wäre irgendwie Spekulation und das müssten wir ja mit dazu sagen. Jungs, das ist jetzt alle Spekulation.
Das ist alles Spekulation hier, verlässt euch. Nicht da drauf.
Genau. Alles ohne Gewehr.
Wir haben auch keine Ahnung.
Nächstes Mal gibt's noch Spekulatius.
Ja, ne.
Wenn man einen Softcake haben wollte, müsst ihr jetzt so grafen bleiben.
So lange können wir aber...
Ich find auf jeden Fall diese iMix total klasse. Vor allem, sie setzen jetzt konkret auf Wireless so. Gibt keine Kabel-Appliances mehr, außer Strom. Die Kabel-Tastatur ist jetzt optional. Wireless kommt serienmäßig und die Maus kommt auch serienmäßig.
Da brauchen sie nur noch Funkstrom.
Und wer die Clitoris-Maus haben will, der kann sie sich auch noch als Apple-Maus mit Kabel bestellen. Aber nicht mehr als Wireless, glaube ich. Was gab's noch neu? Time Capsule, Airport Extreme, haben wir gesagt.
Und zwar, dass die Airport Extreme, da ist ja das einzige neu, dass jetzt anscheinend zwei Antennen wohl drei haben und deswegen dann noch mal ein bisschen mehr Wumms auf der Leitung hinkriegen.
Ja, und zwar, weißt du, was sie hier machen? Hab ich aber jetzt nur so nebenbei gelesen. Habe ich mich nicht wirklich tief reingelesen. Aber der Clou ist wohl, dass sie dann, wenn sie drei Antennen verwenden, vielleicht machen sie das auch schon bei zwei, aber bei drei hast du quasi nochmal 50 Prozent mehr Wumms, sie senden dann auch auf mehreren Frequenzen dasselbe, sodass du sozusagen Redundanz hast. Und wenn irgendwie ein Empfänger das auf dem einen Kanal nicht kriegt, dann kann er das sozusagen parallel gleich auf dem anderen irgendwie...
Ist das diese Mimo-Technik oder wie? Genau, die braucht drei Antennen.
Also die kann bis zu drei Antennen...
Nee, ich glaube, die braucht zwingend drei Antennen.
Dann würde es ja bisher nicht funktioniert haben.
Hat sie auch nicht.
Ach du meinst, Mimo ist es erst, wenn es wirklich drei sind?
Ich glaube ja. Ich weiß es aber nicht genau.
Ich habe es so verstanden, dass es optional ist, bis zu drei.
Das ist ein Beispiel von Spekulation.
Genau.
Und keine Ahnung.
Ich gucke mal hier kurz nach.
Jetzt gucke ich noch mal in die Wave, ob es da nicht noch einen Aspekt hat.
Wir wollen ja auch, dass unsere Hörer ja auch ein bisschen was tun. Wir wollen ja immer nur anfüttern und die Neugierigen machen auf Themen und so richtig reinlesen, muss man sicher.
In der Wave wird spekulisiert, ob jetzt nicht mit dem 27 Zoller mal Zeit wäre für die Auflösungsunabhängigkeit unter OS X.
Ich glaube, das kommt ja nicht mehr so wirklich. Das haben die schon seit 10.04 gesagt und da ist nichts passiert, also so richtig.
Da lohnt es sich echt, glaube ich, drüber zu reden, wenn sie dann wirklich mal eine Ansage machen. Aber vorher brauchen wir da glaube ich nicht mehr wieder drüber nachdenken.
Ja gut, mehr RAM-Troller, da haben wir doch tatsächlich alles gemacht. Ah ja, und das Gehäuse ist jetzt auch Unibody. Das ist natürlich interessant. Und was auch Unibody ist, ist das neue Gehäuse von dem neuen MacBook. Das finde ich ja ganz case, das Gerät.
Ein Unibody-Plastik, oder was?
Ja, das weiße MacBook kommt so ein bisschen runder daher, und das ist ein Unibody. Das heißt, sie machen denselben Spaß jetzt auch da mit ihrem weißen, was ist das überhaupt für ein Kunststoff?
Keine Ahnung, Spekulation.
Sei wohl, Spekulation habe ich gelesen, sei halt auch deutlich verwinderungssteifer als die alte verschrobte Variante. Überrascht jetzt nicht unbedingt, weil das ist halt einfach mal der Vorteil von Unibody, dass es eben stabiler ist. Firewire ist nicht mehr dabei. Damit habe ich gerechnet.
Schon wieder entfernt. Sie probieren es auch immer wieder, ne?
Na gut, aber in dem Produkt sehe ich das auch voll ein.
Die sollen gefälliges USB nutzen.
Versparen Sie sich das halt einfach. Das wendet sich an Leute, die, glaube ich, auch mit USB zufrieden sind. Jetzt ist zumindest mal eine klare Abtrennung. Pro hat Firewire, nicht Pro hat keins.
Das ist das einzige nicht Pro-Gerät, oder? Von den MacBooks, von den Laptops.
Mehr haben sie nicht, aber sie haben eingesehen, dass sie einen Einsteiger-Price-Point liefern müssen. Sie haben das Ding jetzt auch nochmal 50 Euro billiger gemacht. 850 Euro für das Teil. Und alles ist halt aktuell.
Ich finde das ein okayer Rechner.
Das ist, glaube ich, noch ein alter Bildschirm. Das ist kein LED-Bildschirm, oder?
Ich glaube, es ist ein LED-Bildschirm.
Es ist auch ein LED-Bildschirm.
Das ist ja mal Zeit für die Quad-Cores jetzt.
Ja gut, aber bestimmt nicht ein Einschneidermodell, oder? Ich denke mal, das wird so Anfang nächsten Jahres. Wenn nicht noch früher, würde ich mich ein bisschen überraschen. Das letzte große Update...
Hat LED-Hintergrundbeleuchtung auf jeden Fall.
Hat LED-Hintergrundbeleuchtung, ja okay, gut.
Also ich war ja der Erste in meinem Referenzkreis, der irgendwie einen Dual-Core-Laptop hatte.
Das MacBook Air hat natürlich auch keinen.
Und ich will wieder der Erste sein, der einen Quad hat.
Und hat auch ein Glas-Trackpad. Auf das man ja innerhalb von, ihr habt ja alle noch gar keins, aber man gewöhnt sich da so schnell dran.
Auch an den Klicknücken so.
In 17 Zollern war ja früher immer das größte Trackpad von allen drauf. Und jetzt ist es im Vergleich zu den neuen ja auch immer noch klein.
Das ist wirklich, ich hab nach zwei oder drei Wochen, hab ich wieder an einem alten gesessen und fühlte mich plötzlich so richtig eingeschränkt durch dieses kleine Trackpad.
Mit Fingergesten und so, da ist halt überhaupt kein Platz hier.
Ja, ich bin da auch, ich steh auch kurz davor da in eurer Kategorie aufzuschließen.
In seine, also ich hab ja...
Was hast du jetzt bestellt? MacBook Pro 15 Zoll.
Hab ich noch nicht bestellt, aber das ist gerade so meine Option. Jetzt muss ich mich nur noch entscheiden, welche der drei Varianten für mich in Frage kommt. Aber ich glaub, das kann dann nur...
Das kann sich für eine Saison drei, vier Produktzyklen handeln.
Nee, nee, nee, nee, das ist jetzt alles etwa da. Vor allem ich bin auch mit meinem MacBook irgendwie durch. Wir werden jetzt keine Freunde mehr.
Hat ja auch lange genug die Knechtschaft.
Ja, aber ich hab's lange genug geknechtet.
Ich hatte ja auch so ein kleines Problem, das wir letztes Mal gesprochen haben, mit diesen Festplatten, dass das System manchmal hängt. Und da gab's dieses Leistungsupdate. Und das hat tatsächlich was gebracht. Und zwar nicht zu knapp. Die Hänger sind nicht ganz weg, leider. Sie kommen hin und wieder schon nochmal wieder. Aber wesentlich seltener ist es, man kann plötzlich arbeiten wieder an dem Ding. Das war echt ein Drama vorher. Das war so wirklich dieses...
Was war das für ein Update?
Firmware oder Software?
Das ist mit einem Reboot drin gewesen. Insofern war es kein Firmware-Update. Das kam einfach unter dem Namen Leistungs-Update 1.0.
Also ein Software-Update eigentlich vom OS?
Im Wesentlichen wahrscheinlich ein Software-Update. Ich hab wirklich nach der Sendung von extrem vielen Leuten, ich hab noch nie so viel Feedback auf irgendwas bekommen, dass die dieses Problem auch hatten. Bei allen scheint es das nicht gebracht zu haben, aber bei mir ist es im Augenblick...
Scheint jetzt wohl der richtige Zeitpunkt zu sein, auf MacBook Pro um zu steigen. Jetzt hat das langsam so seine Reife wie dieses Gerät. Bevor sie jetzt wieder Next Generation machen, schnell kaufen. Ja, es muss auch echt alles erstmal eine Stunde, erstmal ein Jahr abhängen bei Apple, bevor man das irgendwie wirklich kaufen kann. Hab ich so den Eindruck. Ich scroll jetzt gerade mal hier durch die Wave. Wir haben eine ganze Menge schon erwähnt. Schade, dass man diese Wave......
mit der Hardware jetzt durch?...
abhaken kann. Na ja, es gab noch so eine, die Apple Remote ist irgendwie jetzt auch in Alu, aber...
Für den gleichen Preis.
Ja, mal gucken. Sieht auf jeden Fall nicht mehr so shabby aus, aber es ist halt immer noch Infrarot.
Ich finde die auch immer nicht zu Hause. Dabei ist das schon cool, auch mit VLC es funktioniert. Da kann man sich auf den Sofa legen, so, jo, Pause, weiter. Weißt du eigentlich, dass man mit der...
Aus Glas?
Dass man mit der Plasteremote seinen Rechner schlafen legen kann. Und da die meisten Leute irgendwie die...
Wenn man die Pause-Taste lange drückt.
Die Remote nicht irgendwie bind mit ihrem Rechner. Also hier im Parent, dass du alle Rechner... Also alle Max in deiner Umgebung irgendwie mit seiner Apple Remote irgendwie schlafen legen kannst.
Die Pause-Taste ein bisschen länger gedrückt halten, oder?
Ja, muss sie ziemlich, ziemlich lange drücken. Nein, ich hab meine aus. Ich sehe jetzt gerade die alle... Also ich ja jetzt nicht live, aber viele Leute, die jetzt diese Sendung hören, gerade so sich Ärger eingefangen haben.
Ja, das war auch schon früher auch schon so. Also die allerersten Max, die mal rauskamen, die Fernbedienung hatten, man war das nochmal, das war so Mitte der 90er Jahre, da konnte sie sich auch ausschalten damit. Ja, die haben immer irgendeinen Fail. Genauso wie dieser Cube mit dieser komischen Leuchttasse, die da oben immer drauf war und gesagt hat, ich nehm den Cube ja weiterhin irgendwie eigentlich schick.
Eigentlich ist er schick. Eigentlich ist er schick, aber...
Was, der Cube war eine Design-Katastrophe vom Herrn. Ja, also Design im Sinne von benutzen.
Als man den Reset-Button noch gebraucht hat, das war immer die totale...
Nee, aber zum Beispiel schon die Lautsprecher, oder?
Ja, die lautsprecher mit so kurzen Kabeln, die immer über den Tisch rollen.
Das hat noch spezielle Konnektoren.
Ja, du kannst keine anderen anschließen, sondern diese Teile.
Nee, die hatten einen eigenen Konnektor für irgendwie Audio-Out.
Nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein.
Doch, doch, doch, doch. Ich hab mir einen Cube noch irgendwie...
Ich hatte auch genug Cubes. Das war USB.
Aber dann ging es auch nur mit dem Cube-USB-Port, der noch mal extra super mehr Power geliefert hat für diese Teile. Und das Kabel war zu kurz. Und die ganzen Stecker waren unten hinter so einer Glaswand versteckt. Wenn du mal irgendwas in diesen Rechner reinstecken musstest, musstest du sie irgendwie immer umkippen. Mit dem Ergebnis, dass er das dann auch tat. Aber das geilste war wirklich...
Leute, die sich so einen Rechner kaufen, der steht da und die fassen ihn nicht mehr an. Und wenn du mal den Faktor anguckst, dann ist es so, als wenn du den Mac Mini genauso rausgezogen hätten und den Plastorahmen weggelassen hätten.
Es gibt ja auch Leute, die den Cube fassen.
Du fass den deshalb nicht mehr an, weil wenn du den anfasst, dann machst du ihn kaputt.
Normalerweise fasst man seinen Rechner nicht mehr an, wenn man einen aufgestellt hat. Also andere Leute machen das so.
Bitte USB anschließen, Firewire reinstecken.
Hat man damals nicht so oft gemacht? Damals gab es auch keine Sticks.
Hat man nicht so oft gemacht? Jedes einzelne Mal, wo du es machst, ist es einfach ein Schmerz im Arsch gewesen. Dieses Gerät war einfach ein Fail.
Das war eine eindeutige Fehlmedie mit deiner Seite.
Das Geilste war am Anfang, da mussten sie ja noch ein Betriebssystem fixen. Dieser Einschaltbutton obendrauf, dieser Softtouch, der die ganze Zeit vor sich hin leuchtete. Das Ding steht da, ihr könnt wirklich auf die Uhr gucken, es dauert immer keine 60 Sekunden. Jemand kommt irgendwie rein und sagt, oh ein Cube, der sieht ja toll aus. Was ist denn das da?
Der ist schon ausgeschaltet oder schlafen gelegt.
Dann mussten sie später in einem Software-Update erst noch diese Option, dass man diesen Button ausschaltet, hinzufügen, um das einfach zu fixen. Ja, weil alle so, oh was ist denn das?
Ich fand diesen Schornsteller drin, den finde ich nach wie vor ziemlich geil. Den was? Damit er keinen Lüfter braucht.
Von unten anlüftet und von oben weg.
Weil die Hardware so im...
Der war viel zu teuer.
Ja, das war er auf jeden Fall. Viel zu teuer. Als sie den dann eingestellt haben, haben sie noch Reste abverkauft. Am Anfang war der tatsächlich total überteuert, aber dann war das okay. Kauft euch keine Cubes mehr, die haben auch keine Modell.
Passt der Mac Mini in so einem Cube-Gehäuse? Das muss man sich ja fett umbauen.
Es gibt Leute, die fahren Mac Mini in Cube-Gehäuse.
Wenn du am Cube die Kabel rausziehst, dann kannst du das Cube-Gehäuse so mit Cube drinnen oben draufstellen. Auf so einem Mac Mini. Dann hängt der genau drauf. Hab ich mal probiert.
Wollen wir mal irgendwie auf Finanzen kommen?
Ich wollte gerade sagen, das war ja auch letzten Monat, einen Tag bevor die neuen Rechnungen. Was ist das?
Ich hab mir so einen Stick gekauft.
Wo steckst du den denn jetzt hin?
Hast du den letzte Mal schon erzählt? Letztes Mal hatte ich den noch nicht. Insofern hatte ich das letzte Mal schon erzählt.
Du hattest den nicht dabei.
Du hattest den nicht dabei, ja.
Nee, ich hatte den das letzte Mal nicht. Ich hab den von der Woche gekauft.
Schon wieder einen neuen?
Das lass ich doch mal erzählen, Dennis. Das ist so ein Huawei-Teil.
Nee, es ist nicht.
Alles ist Huawei.
Nein, nein, nein, es ist kein Huawei.
Sondern?
XSstick W14. Ich hab, wie heißen die? 4gsystems.com. Und das war...
Kannst du nochmal genau die Modellbezeichnung sagen, die da drauf steht?
XSstick W14.
XS-Stick?
XS-Lehrzeichen-Stick.
Ja?
Lehrzeichen W14. Und der...
Was kommt als erstes bei Google-UMTS-Stick XS-W14?
Genau das hatte ich nämlich, ich hab solche Horror-Storys gehört, dass es dies mit USB-Sticks geben soll, mit so... mit UMTS-Sticks und dann Mac OSC und Snow Leopard und was ist der Teufel? Snow Leopard.
Und das Ding war Anstecken. Wie heißt diese Firma?
Wie heißt diese Firma, die du eben genannt hast?
4G Systems. 4G Minus Systems. Und ich bin so treu doof zu Saturn gegangen, hab mir da den billigsten HSDPA, HSU-PA-Stick geben lassen für 45 Euro ohne SimLog, ohne alles. Hab gefragt, ob der auch unter Mac OSC läuft, haben die tapfer genickt und hab gedacht, naja ok, bin ich wahrscheinlich später in einem Schnull wieder da und tauschen um. Das war aber nicht der Fall. Da ist eine zwar extrem hässliche, aber ohne irgendwie Installation, ohne Neustartfunktion, eine Software dabei. Man steckt das Ding an und hat Netz. Und das ohne irgendwelche Kernel, Treiber und weißer Teufel was.
Du hast keine Treiber installiert?
Ich hab keinerlei Treiber installiert.
Als Modem?
Ja, das meldet sich als Modem ab.
Das kriegt auch...
Genau. Da ist aber eine Software dabei, die startet sobald das Ding...
Wie, da ist eine Software dabei? Da ist eine Software auf dem Stick?
Da ist eine Software auf dem Stick. Also das erste, der mountet sich als... Da ist noch offensichtlich so ein kleines Datalsystem drinne. Der mountet sich als Volume. Und nach der ersten Installation, sobald die Software... Sobald da intelligent genug ist, die Volume automatisch auszuwerfen, sodass nicht jedes Mal, wenn du es abziehst, eine Warnmeldung kriegst, da war eine Speicherplatte, eine Festplatte, die abgezogen worden ist, ohne das... Das ist eine relativ gut durchdachte Lösung.
Was ist da jetzt drauf auf diesem...
Das heißt XS-Manager. Es sieht ganz, ganz furchtbar aus.
Also wir reden von einer Mac OS X-Applikation. Und die macht dann was? Die PIN-Geschichte und so?
Die macht die PIN-Geschichte, die macht SMS, die macht Internetverbindung herstellen. Die hat so einen kleinen Verbinden-Button, den klickt man und dann hat man Internet.
Und dann hast du auch gleich das Setup und das entsprechende Modem-Profil. Läuft. Ist alles dabei.
Es war anstecken, läuft.
Ja, warum nicht?
Also die Software sieht, wie gesagt, die sieht jetzt wirklich nicht doller aus, aber sie tut, was sie soll.
Okay, ist das schon mal was.
Was allerdings ein totales Drama war...
Wenn man auf der Webseite kommt, kommt irgendwie nichts vorhanden.
Wenn man die SIM-Karte nicht drinstecken hat und das Ding dann reinsteckt oder die SIM-Karte nicht richtig drinsteckt, dann tiltet der Mac auch total durch. Also dann hat man auch ein echtes Problem. Aber solange man sich halbwegs an die Regeln hält, klappt das. Also bisher eine ganz gute Lösung, wie ich finde.
Okay, ist das schon mal was.
Und 45 Euro für HS-UPA.
Ah, die macht auch HS-UPA. Was kriegst du da so für Upload-Raten raus?
Das hab ich ehrlich gesagt noch gar nicht so genau ausprobiert. Ich hab das ein paar Mal im Café genutzt.
Macht O2 überhaupt HS-UPA?
Soweit ich weiß, ja.
Soweit ich weiß, machen sie es nicht.
Soweit ich weiß, aber ich weiß es nicht.
Ich hab noch keinen größeren Upload gemacht mit. Ich hab da einfach den billigsten Stück mir aus dem Laden gegriffen.
Okay, verstehe. Also 4gsystems.com ist definitiv nicht Huawei. Ich dachte mal, das wär auch nur so ein Huawei, aber wir sind alle gleich weiß mittlerweile. Das ist doch mal was. 45 Euro und du kriegst das ohne Karte oder was?
Ohne Karte, ohne alles, ohne SIM-Lock.
Wo kauft man das?
Bei Saturn hab ich das geholt.
Hängt da so rum, UMTS.
Das hab ich gefragt und dann haben die mir das rausgegeben. Ich hätte gern was ohne SIM-Lock, ohne alles, ohne Vertrag.
Okay, das wär ja dann wieder ein Argument, sein iPhone zu aktualisieren.
Ah stimmt, da gibt's ja jetzt auch, da gibt's ja mittlerweile auch einen Trick, wie man Tessering und 9.3.1 zum Laufen kriegt. Nach einer Jailbreak. Es gibt leider noch keine Installationskandidaten.
Man muss zwei Bytes irgendwie im Comcenter ändern.
Es gibt, genau, erstens zwei Bytes, das Comcenter-Patchen.
Was ist denn bitte das Comcenter?
Das Tool, was die Verbindung zum Baseband macht, wahrscheinlich.
Ah, also eine Applikation auf dem iPhone.
Und die Alternative dazu ist eine Software, ich glaube namens MyWi oder MyWiFi, oder wie die heißt, zu kaufen. MyWi?
Huawei und MyWi.
Und die kostet irgendwie 10 Dollar. Macht im Wesentlichen auch das. Also das Tethering wieder geht, macht aber gleich noch WLAN-Tethering an. Was natürlich auch ganz okay ist.
Wie man kann im Zydiastore für 10 Dollar Programme kaufen, die sich das iPhone rumknacken im Ei?
Ja klar.
Also Knacker, die Geld nehmen, die werden alle erschossen.
Find ich jetzt relativ hart, aber wieso?
Das ist die Frage, was sie verkaufen. Wenn sie nur Software verkaufen, die es nicht im App Store gibt, ist das was anderes, als wenn sie Software verkaufen, die es im App Store gibt.
Entweder sie hacken, oder die machen so Commerz-Scheiße.
Genau, und die hacken unten und machen Commerz-Scheiße. Das geht nicht.
Commerz-Hacker sind einfach immer uncool.
Okay, und irgendwann meint es, dass es mittlerweile ein Paket gibt, das Tesserang auch wieder einfach aktiviert.
Ach ja, dazu habe ich mich ja schon irgendwie ausgelassen. Jetzt kommen wir mal zu den Finanzen.
Genau.
So, was macht Apple in der größten Wirtschaftskrise der USA?
Gewinnen.
So viel Gewinn wie noch nie. Und es gab das erste Mal mehr als 3 Millionen verkaufte Macintoshes. In einem Quartal. Was ja schon erheblich ist. Interessant fand ich auch, dass die Desktops dann doch einen starken Trend nach unten zeigten. Und das ist sozusagen diese Marke.
Das haben die aber schon seit Jahren schon gesagt.
Ja, aber noch nie war das Verhältnis so krass. Also sie haben über zwei Millionen Laptops verkauft. Vor zwei, drei Jahren hat Apple noch nicht mal zwei Millionen Macintoshes überhaupt verkauft.
Also da war das... Aber wer braucht auch eine Workstation?
Wer braucht auch zwei Millionen MacBooks?
Ich brauch eine Workstation.
Ja, klar, aber das ist so der...
Du bist der Letzte.
Aber wenn jetzt so ein quasi 8-Core-iMac, 27 Zoll, mit so einem Gerät und schick und slick und so und ohne Kabel, da ist so der Bedarf für jetzt ein Mac Pro noch unterm Tisch, ein extra Display und ganz viele Kabel, da muss man schon wirklich großen Performance-Hunger haben und wirklich Platz für zwei Grafikkarten brauchen und einen Fiber-Channel und was nicht alles, was du halt an einem iMac nicht kriegst. Aber es sind halt nicht so viele Leute, die diesen hohen Performance-Anspruch dann haben. Also auch nicht nur in Sachen Geschwindigkeit, sondern eben auch Ausbau. Weiß nicht, wie viel RAM da reingeht in so einen Mac Pro, aber bestimmt auch so eher 32 GB und so. 4 Platten.
Na gut, ich meine, Desktop sind das natürlich vor allem iMacs. Und die Mac Pros, denke ich mal, spielen sehr geringen Anteil. Ich weiß nicht, wie viele das sind, aber das ist bestimmt.
Aber die iMacs werden jetzt bestimmt mal wieder ordentlich ziehen.
Das denke ich auch. Also ich glaube, die iMacs, die werden definitiv nochmal eine ganze Menge ziehen. Ja, also gut geht es ihnen. Und das ist ja auch sehr erfreulich. Und sie haben auch mal wieder ganz viel Geld verdient. Bei den iPhones haben sie komischerweise nur um 7% zugelegt. Halt ich ja für ein bisschen wenig. Aber es gibt ja diese Gerüchteküche, dass sie immer wieder gar nicht hinterher kommen.
Mit der Produktion?
Mit der Produktion. Oder mit der Auslieferung, weiß ich nicht. Und dann gab es noch diesen merkwürdigen Kommentar von Tim Cook, dass sie davon ausgehen, dass im First Quarter, das ist sozusagen das jetzt, das Weihnachtsquartal ist ja das First Quarter, dass sie erhöhte Air Freight-Costs haben werden, die abnormal steigen sollen. Und das habe nichts mit dem iPhone zu tun.
Das ist ja dann am nächsten Tag gelöst, woran es liegt.
Getting Units into the Channel for the Holiday.
Weil die neuen IMAX rauskamen und der ganze Kram. Kommen wir am nächsten Tag.
Achso, dass sie die alle per Luftpost verschicken, damit sie schneller da sind.
Dann machen sie doch eh immer, oder?
Das kann gut sein, aber warum?
Weil sie die packen, die auf so einem Schiff warten. Bis dahin gibt es neue CPUs.
Warum kostet sie das jetzt mehr als sonst?
Weil jetzt zu viel gekauft wird, wenn neue Geräte rauskommen.
Die werden auch per Schiff transportiert, natürlich.
Glaube ich nicht.
Max? Von China nach Amerika?
Ein Flug ist jetzt auch nicht so teuer.
Von China nach Amerika mit einem Schiff sind die vier Wochen unterwegs.
Das geht doch halt schneller.
Genau, die fliegen übers Wasser. Was denkst du, wie schnell so ein Schiff ist?
Ich hab mal ein Shipment gemacht, das dauert schon ein paar Tage. Man sieht es ja, wenn du einen bestellst, kannst du ja so tracken. Dann ist es so, ja, jetzt Hongkong, und zwei Tage später sind die dann in Europa.
Da wird schon viel geflogen. So ein Schiff fährt maximal 30, 40 Sachen.
Er redet ja auch wirklich von Air Freight-Kosts.
Nein, nein, wenn du ein neues Produkt hast, das du schnell in die Kanäle treiben willst, dass du dann erstmal die per Luftlieferung auslieferst. Aber dass du danach natürlich das iPhone, an dem ändert sich jetzt nicht so unglaublich viel, das kannst du auch ruhig langsam per Schiff durchgegeben.
Aber das iPhone hat so eine kleine Verpackung, da kannst du auch...
Ja, da brauchst du auch ein paar Stück von, und bei den iMacs sieht es dann genauso aus. Nach dem Weihnachtsgeschäft kannst du die jetzt schon in Schiff packen, damit die dann im Januar ankommen.
Aber meinst du, dass es für Schiffen wirklich billiger ist?
Ja, sonst müsste es ja nicht so massenhaft gemacht werden.
Ja, mit ganz anderen Waren, aber auch die viel größer sind.
Ja, auch mit kleinen Waren.
So ein iPhone kannst du ja schon, die Verpackung ist ja klein genug. Das kannst du jetzt in so einem Flugzeug, auch in einem Passagier-Jet, in alle möglichen Ritzen erst.
Das wird so den Gessen... Könntet ihr das noch bitte mitnehmen?
Genau, da steht so ein Apple-Mitarbeiter am Flughafen, kann man das für uns noch...
Das ist der eigentliche Grund, warum man keine Gepäckstücke von fremden Leuten mitnehmen soll.
Genau, weil es alles nur Schmuggel ist. Ok, kommen wir wieder zurück zum Thema. Da gab es ja noch eine Ansage in den Zahlen, also in den Analysen später, dass sie meinten, sie hätten 7% mehr iPhones verkauft, als im gleichen Zeitraum im Jahr vorher. Und ich fand ja, 7% mehr iPhones ist ja ganz schön wenig. Aber es liegt, glaube ich, daran, dass der Verkaufsstart, also wann das neue Gerät rauskam, war dieses Jahr ein anderes Datum als letztes Jahr. Das heißt, da waren irgendwie 2-3 Wochen dazwischen und da war genau so ein Quartalssprung dazwischen. Das heißt, ich glaube, dieses Jahr haben sie auch erst, entweder jetzt früher oder später angefangen. Jetzt kommt je nachdem, in welches Quartal dieser Start reingeht. Aber ich glaube, daran liegt das.
Jetzt sind die Leute schon wieder mit der Maus über dem Icons-Icon von Boba Max und dann wird wieder kommentiert.
Wir wissen ja wieder nix. Wann kam denn das iPhone dieses Jahr raus?
Ich wusste das, wenn du das sagst.
Letztes Jahr war es doch so, da kamen die iPhones raus und dann war genau irgendwie ein Tag später das Quartal zu Ende. Ich guck mal. Die ersten zwei Tage mit in...
Also es war auf jeden Fall nach dem Kongress, nicht?
Ich bitte dich.
Und es war vor dem Winteranfang.
19. Juni 2000.
Siehste, ich hätte auch das gesagt.
Und das 3G kam im 11. Juli raus.
Ja, fast einen Monat später.
Das heißt, da ist sozusagen ein Verkauf, ging dann noch. Bis wann geht das Quartal?
Ich glaube genau bis 22. Juni oder so was. Ein paar Tage nach dem Verkaufsstart letztes Jahr.
Nee, nee.
Na, es ist jetzt am 19. Juni rausgebracht worden.
Dieses Jahr?
Ja.
I'm lost. Jedenfalls kann man das deswegen nicht so vergleichen, weil die beiden Starts des iPhones halt quadralsmäßig unterschiedlich sind.
Ist ja auch scheißegal. Auf jeden Fall verkauft sich das ganz ordentlich und ich denk mal, sie werden jetzt im Holiday dann auch noch mal ein bisschen abliefern. Wobei das Jahr letztes Mal war es halt dann weniger als vorher. Also die meisten kaufen sozusagen, wenn es neu ist. Und dann nicht mehr so sehr zu Weihnachten.
Ja, warum soll man sich zu Weihnachten auch noch ein iPhone kaufen?
Kaufen lassen.
Ich hab mir mein iPhone...
Zu breit, da warte ich aufs nächste.
Ich hab mein iPhone nach Weihnachten.
Ich weiß, ich weiß. Viele Leute haben sich zu Weihnachten noch eins geschoppt, als persönliche Belohnung. Weil heutzutage kauft man sich seine Weihnachtsgeschenke ja selber.
Oder man lässt sich einfach ein Freies schenken.
So ist das. So, was haben wir denn hier noch in unserer Wave? Genau, ich hatte ja mal den Huckel vor allem hier herangeholt, um mal ein bisschen über die Bewegung bei Mank Ruby, bei Mank Ruby Projekt zu sprechen. Da gab es auch ein Release gerade.
Ein Beta-Release.
Ein Beta-Release war das? Nummer?
05. 05. Beta 1.
Und kannst du mal einen Management Summary kurz geben, was Mank Ruby genau ist und was sich jetzt da sozusagen abzeichnet? Also Ruby ist eine Programmiersprache, wer es nicht weiß. Und so eine wie Python hält seine sogenannte Skript-Sprache in Anführung stehen. Das trifft es aber nicht so richtig. Ja, da kommen wir jetzt drauf.
Genau, also Ruby ist schon, kann man schon sagen, so eine Skript-Sprache wie Python erst mal so. Die sind schon sehr ähnlich.
Also es ist eine Programmiersprache.
Genau. Ping. Und Apple hat halt schon seit 10.4 liefern die Mac OS mit Ruby, mit dem Ruby-Interpreter, mit dem Python und dem Perl ja aus, so. Also dabei war das bei Mac OS schon eine ganze Weile. Und da gab es dann halt Jungs, oder so ein Projekt namens Hot Cocor, die haben halt, also es gab, genau, Apple hat dann noch eine Skripting-Bridge reingebaut ins Mac OS, dass du halt mit Python und Ruby irgendwie auch, weiß ich nicht, konntest du dann Mac OS abskripten, so wie Apple Skript, es gab halt irgendwie eine Bridge, so einen sogenannten Bridge Support. Was man damit genau gemacht hat, weiß ich ehrlich gesagt auch gar nicht. Jedenfalls nicht viel, weil viele Leute haben das gar nicht benutzt. So, und dann gab es HotCocor. Und HotCocor war halt auf dieser Bridge aufsetzend die Möglichkeit, dass man mit Ruby Cocor-Applikationen schreiben konnte. Und zwar gibt's da auch, also es gibt zwei oder drei, die man so kennt, es gibt einen Irk-Klein-Lime-Chat oder so, der auch relativ populär so ist, weil man das bei Irk-Kleins überhaupt noch sagen kann. Und der war mit HotCocor gemacht. Und ja, so war erst mal der Stand. Also gab halt ein paar Leute, die angefangen haben, mit Ruby Cocor abzustricken.
Hast du das auch mal gemacht, oder?
Nee, weil das war halt total umständlich.
Das war furchtbar, oder?
Weil diese Bridge, man hat dann halt irgendwie in dem Ruby auf einmal mit den Cocor- und Objective-C-Namespaces rumgehandiert und musste dann dauernd irgendwelche komischen Dinge schreiben, um da an die Objekte zu kommen. Und war halt alles ganz umständlich. Naja, und jetzt auf jeden Fall gab es dann den Laurent Sansonetti, irgendein französischer Hacker. Der hat sich gedacht, wir könnten doch jetzt hier mal irgendwie richtig Cocor- und Objective-C- und Ruby verheiraten. Und hat halt angefangen, diese Mac-Ruby-Implementierung oder Mac-Ruby zu coden. Und es ist tatsächlich halt ein eigener Interpret, also eine eigene Implementierung. Es ist jetzt nicht so, dass sie einfach das Standard-Ruby nehmen und da halt so wie vorher mit Hot Cocor irgendwie das Objective-C so ranbügeln mit Bridge Support und hier so eine Tacker-Klammer und da eine Tacker-Klammer, sondern der hat halt irgendwie angefangen.
Dazu muss man sagen, der Typ ist ja Teil des Mac OS X Colonel Teams, oder? Wenn ich das richtig erinnere. Ich hab mal einen Vortrag von ihm gesehen, wo er über Mac-Ruby geredet hat. Und er wurde als... Ich glaube auf einer Ruby-Konferenz. Ruby-Con oder so. Und da hat er das im Prinzip schon mal vorgestellt und hat sich selber als Mitarbeiter vom Darwin-Team, glaube ich, vorgestellt.
Also der hat das halt auch erstmal ohne Apple als Supporter angefangen und irgendwann hat dann Apple gesagt, das ist ja viel cooler auch als Hot Cocoa und wir nehmen das jetzt auf Mac OS Forge mit auf und machen das jetzt ein offizielles Projekt mit dem Ziel, dass dieses Hot Cocoa halt auch ersetzt werden soll mit Mac Ruby.
Genau, und da wird halt Ruby mit Objective-C quasi verheiratet, weil sie einfach dieselbe Foundation benutzt sind. Wir haben das ja auch schon ein paar Mal besprochen. Hier und ich fand das ja insofern, also ich hab mich immer gefragt, ok, warum steigt da Apple jetzt so ein? Wir sehen ja, sie können sowas auch schnell wieder fallen lassen wie eine kreise Kartoffel, aber das heißt, das kann auch durchaus sein, dass da, was weiß ich, im halben Jahr steht da wieder, this project has been closed und geh weg.
Oder Java haben sie ja auch gestiegen.
Ja, bei Ruby ist es halt schon so, dass nicht nur Apple das embracen sozusagen. Microsoft hat ja jetzt auch hier in Dortnet einen eigenen Ruby-Interpreter oder eine eigene Ruby-Implementierung gemacht. Es gibt JRuby, die auch von Sun sozusagen bis vor kurzem auf jeden Fall supported wurde. Und Apple gibt halt richtig Gas mit dem Support. Sie hatten ja schon, wie gesagt, seit 10.4 Ruby-Interpreter standardmäßig drauf. Dann haben sie in 10.5, oder war das schon auch schon in 10.4, hatten sie auch Ruby on Rails, dieses Web-Framework schon mit drauf. Und dann hatten sie ja irgendwie den iPhone-Konfigurator oder irgendwelche komischen Apps hatten sie auch schon in Rails selber gestrickt sogar. Also man hat schon gemerkt, die sind ja prinzipiell schon ganz Ruby und Ruby on Rails-affin und finden halt auch diese Dynamik in der Community da ganz attraktiv.
Diese iPhone-Konfigurationstool ist eine Rails-Anwendung. Also die App, die sie da ausliefern, ist eine Rails-Anwendung, wo dann sozusagen ein kleiner Webserver gestartet wird.
Genau. So und bis Version 0.3 von diesem Mac-Ruby war das eben halt so, auch schon ein ganz schönes Gefrickel, war noch an den Standard-Ruby-Interpreter irgendwie drangebamselt oder an den Standard-Ruby-Byte-Compiler, ne Quatsch, an die Virtual Machine, genau. Und jetzt haben sie halt angefangen zu sagen, ja pass mal auf, irgendwie, also man muss noch sagen, bei Ruby gibt's halt keine echten Threads zum Beispiel. Was so ein kleiner Nachteil von Ruby ist. Die Sprache. Ja, von der Sprache ist in Sachen Performance und der Garbage-Collector von denen zum Beispiel ist auch nicht so der Herr Bringer. Also Ruby ist eine langsame Programmierung. Nicht so langsam wie PHP, aber so. Genau. So, dann haben sie halt in...
Java ist nicht langsam. Das ist Mythos, also Java ist schnell.
So, was sie jetzt halt eben bei diesem Mac-Ruby 05 gemacht haben, also, naja, es ist gar nicht so einfach, da so den richtigen Einstiegspunkt zu finden. Also was man noch zu diesem Mac-Ruby sagen muss im Vergleich zu allem, was da vorher war und mit Bridge Support und so weiter und so fort, alles in Ruby erbt von NSObject. Also die sind nicht irgendwie so da dran gebamselt, die Cocoa-Objekte, sondern man hat sie direkt an der Hand. Also in dem Moment, wo ich einen Array aufmache, so eckige Klammer, 1,2,3, eckige Klammer zu und frag nach der Klasse, habe ich NSMutableArray statt die normale RubyArray-Klasse sozusagen.
Und ein String ist ein NSString und so weiter.
Du schreibst Ruby, wie man Ruby schreiben würde. Sie haben sich auch echt Mühe gegeben, ihr Objective-C und ihren Cocoa-Syntax möglichst ins Ruby zu übersetzen. Du musst dich nicht verbiegen und dann auf einmal hier mit eckige Klammer, Objektname, Leerzeichen, Methodenname und so weiter, wie man halt Objective-C sozusagen schreiben würde. Du kannst halt richtig natürliches Ruby schreiben. Sie haben sich da echt Mühe gegeben. Und du hast eben komplett die Objective-C und Cocoa-Welter, die direkt runter. Und statt zum Beispiel jetzt die Ruby-Standard-Library zu benutzen, um HTTP-Requests zu machen, kannst du halt einfach sagen, ich hätte jetzt gerne ein NSURL-Request-with-String. So, schreibst du halt genauso hin, als wäre das schon immer da gewesen. Du hast an allen Objekten, also wenn du jetzt zum Beispiel...
Also du hast sozusagen das komplette OS-10-Frame, alle OS-10-Frameworks sind einfach da. Es ist einfach alles da, es ist alles benutzbar. Und du kannst deine nativen Strings und Bites und Arrays und so weiter übergeben, als wär's alles Objective-C.
Ja, und was noch krass ist, also was wirklich krass ist, dass du zum Beispiel einen String da hinschreibst, so ein Litte, also wie man halt Ruby schreibt, da macht man nicht erst irgendwie einen neuen String-Objekt und dann steckt man die Zeichen rein, sondern schreibt man einfach den String hin. Wenn du da dann die Methoden dir anzeigen lässt, dann gibt's halt einmal alle Ruby-Methoden, die es auf Strings gibt. Und du kannst aber auch einfach direkt Punkt und dann alle Objective-C-Methoden, die es für Strings gibt. Also die haben einfach alles da.
Also alle Framework-Methoden.
Also du kannst halt Punkt up-Case, so wie es in Ruby heißt, und in Objective-C, wie heißt da, uppercase oder keine Ahnung. Man kann da einfach beides benutzen. Der große Vorteil ist daran, statt die Ruby-Standard-Library zu benutzen, um HTTP-Requests zu machen, kannst du eben diesen NSURL-Request machen und der ist dann halt auch gleich multithreaded und asynchron. Das heißt, du kannst dann gleich so die ganze Performance von diesem Cocoa auch mitbenutzen. Weiterhin haben sie dann halt...
Und HTTPS und alle eingebauten Zertifikate und so weiter.
Genau, genau, genau. Du kannst einfach direkt durchgreifen. So, was halt auch noch extrem schön ist, dass sie jetzt einen eigenen Bytecode-Compiler geschrieben haben auf Basis von LLVM. Das heißt, sie benutzen jetzt nicht mehr den Standard-Bytecode-Compiler, sondern haben einen eigenen gehackt, was ein sehr ambitioniertes Ziel eigentlich ist, schreiben sie auch selber. Aber sie haben es halt geschafft. Der ist jetzt nicht nur schneller als der Original-Ruby-Bytecode-Compiler, sondern er ist auch in der Lage, Macho-Executables zu produzieren. Das heißt, man kann Ruby im.rb-Fall nehmen, schickt das nach MacRubyC, heißt das Executable, und rausfällt halt ein echtes MachO-Executable.
MacRubyC ist dann ein MacRuby-Compiler, richtig?
Genau. Und das hat halt auch keine andere Implementierung von Ruby, dass du halt wirklich Executables da draus machen kannst.
Die laufen nativ, ohne dass ich MacRuby brauche. Also die kann ich auf jeder Plattform...
Fat Binaries können sie jetzt auch seit Kurzem.
Das heißt, man kann vielleicht demnächst auch mit Ruby iPhone-Applikationen haben?
Das wäre jetzt meine nächste Frage gewesen.
Genau, kommen wir gleich zu. Also auf jeden Fall kann man jetzt auf dem Mac, also Mac-Applikationen superkomfortabel in Ruby hacken, weil du hast auch volle Interface-Builder-Integration in dem Moment, wo du halt in der Ruby-Klasse Attribute-Accessors machst, also Instance-Variablen, werden die im Interface-Builder als Outlets zum Buttons drannageln, exportiert und so weiter.
Kannst du in Xcode auch gleich sagen, ich will hier ein Ruby-Programm schreiben?
Wenn du Mac-Ruby installierst, dann gibt er dir auch die ganzen Ruby-Templates gleich. Also du kannst dann direkt sagen, ich will jetzt hier ein Mac-Ruby-Projekt aufmachen. Es gibt auch ein, zwei Screencasts schon, die das auch mal so ganz schnell illustrieren, wie man da irgendwie so eine Twitter-App oder so zusammenstreckt mit Ruby. Und das ist einfach extrem schön, weil man superwenig Boilerplate braucht. Also, ihr wisst schon, hier so, iB Outlet, Doppelpunkt, hier und da, jetzt kommt eine Action, iB Action, hast du nicht gesehen, dann schreibste, bla, bla, bla, was jetzt nicht alles gleich kommt.
Wo schreibst du denn hin, damit es im Interface-Bilder kommt?
Ich mach halt irgendwie eine Klasse auf und sag, was da für Instanzvariablen gibt, oder? So. Und dann sind diese Instanzvariablen gleich automatisch irgendwie. Also, das ist ganz schick. Man muss sich mal die Screencasts angucken. Das kann man jetzt über einen Podcast, glaube ich, nicht so gut vermitteln, aber es ist halt wirklich...
Aber ich meine, ich schreibe halt all die Autotinten, damit genau nur die im Interface-Bilder kommen und nicht alle. Ja, ja, ja, das kennt halt Ruby nicht so genau. Und die andere Sache ist, dass du meinst, hier bei NS-String muss man immer erst irgendwie schreiben, bla, bla, bla, stringen, und hast du nicht gesehen, du kannst in Objective-C auch schreiben. My String gleich, Add-Zeichen, Anführungszeichen, String, Anführungszeichen, fertig. Wenn du dann normal Anführungszeichen machst, kriegst du halt einen C-String, weil das ja Objective-C ist ja mit C gemischt.
Ich weiß schon.
Und wie sieht's dann aus, wenn du... Naja, muss man ja auch mal vergleichen, wenn du... Du hast, sagen wir mal, eine Lip wie... Keine Ahnung, Open SSL oder Z-Lip oder was auch immer du so reinlegen willst. Wie machst du denn das dann in Ruby? Geht das auch? Dass du direkt dann die Chords von so einer Lip nutzen kannst, weil das ist ja das Schöne an Objective-C-Kanal. C-Chord irgendwie, also eigentlich ist es ja C.
Naja, also angeblich kann man die auch alle mitbenutzen. So extensiv hab ich's ehrlich gesagt selber noch nicht benutzt, aber... Ich kann euch ja für die Sendung noch ein paar Links mitgeben. Was ich aber noch sagen wollte auf jeden Fall ist, dass sie eben noch zwei andere gute Sachen eingebaut haben. Erstens haben sie auch noch einen Garbage-Collector in eigenem geschrieben, der halt viel performanter ist, weil bei Ruby ist es so, in dem Moment, wo der Garbage-Collector anspringt, steht halt so die ab, weil die hat halt keine echten Threads. Alles halt echte POSIX-Threads und Multithreads, den hast du nicht gesehen und dadurch ist halt der Garbage-Collector viel schneller und sie haben halt auch Grand Central Dispatch jetzt mit eingebaut, was jetzt ja so die große Neuerung auch bei 10.6 war, wo sie halt irgendwie den Entwicklern die Arbeit abnehmen, sich um Multithreading zu kümmern, sondern sagen, hier ist so ein Threadpool.
Hau mal letzte Sendung aus, das hab ich völlig dargelegt.
So, das kann man eben jetzt auch in Macruby benutzen und auch relativ elegant. Das heißt, man kann jetzt Multithreaded, Garbage-Collected, Binaries in Macruby hacken, die dann mit Interface-Bilder zusammendrahten und halt schicke, schnelle...
Sind es denn schon irgendwelche Beispiele, wo jemand mal so eine größere App zusammengehauen hat, die man so runterladen kann, um sich das mal so anzugucken?
Na, die sind jetzt... Es fängt eigentlich jetzt erst gerade so richtig an, weil 04 war einfach noch nicht komplett genug. So, von Sprachfeatures und 05, wenn das halt stable wird, dann geht's glaube ich richtig los. Also es stehen schon ein paar Leute in den Startlöchern, aber...
Also ich find das, ich find das super spannend, weil ehrlich gesagt, Objective-C, da gibt es unterschiedliche Meinungen darüber, aber das schreckt manche Leute einfach ab.
Du sagst jetzt nur, weil ich hier bin.
Ja, das Schöne ist einfach, die kriegen halt durch die Ruby-Community...
Objective-C ist einfach so eine Sprache, die hat diesen Nimbus, dass sie einfach Apple-only ist, und das ist einfach auch die Wahrheit. Objective-C hat außerhalb von Lekko S10...
Das ist ja nichts Schlechtes.
Darüber gibt es unterschiedliche Ansichten. Leute sind nicht bereit, eine Sprache zu lernen, die ihnen das Gefühl gibt, dass sie da nur auf dem Mac was mit anfangen können, aber auf anderen Plattformen stehen sie da. Das ist bei Ruby natürlich ganz anders, insbesondere im Hinblick auf die Universalität von Ruby im Web.
Ruby zu lernen, ich weiß jetzt nicht, wie schwer es ist, aber ich denke, man ist jetzt auch nicht so das Schwere. Objective-C ist auch relativ easy, das Schwere ist, du musst die ganzen Frameworks und die Zusammenarbeiten rausfinden. Und das muss er jetzt, wenn er Mac-Ruby macht, auch rausfinden. Also letztens saß einer neben mir, unser Biafra, saß neben mir, guck ich so, ist er da vorher irgendwie am Machen und irgendwie auch mit iPhone und so. Ich warte, Dirk, jetzt auch hier iPhone-Programmierungen, ist doch Objective-C, ja wieso, ist so ein bisschen eckige Klammer und es ist doch sonst überall Wonders auch. Also ich meine, hat er sich eine Woche angeguckt und dann ging es.
Ich sage ja nicht, dass das nicht geht, und ich sage aber nicht, dass das keiner macht. Ich sage nur, ich kenne genug Leute, die sich davon abgeschreckt fühlen. Ob die sich dazu recht... Ob die sich dazu recht von abgeschreckt fühlen, sei jetzt mal dahingestellt. Es ist aber so, dass das einfach so ist. Diese Sprache ist auf Next geboren worden und lebt einfach nur Mac OS X. Kein Wunder, ich meine, die Kernobjekte fangen alle mit NS an. Warum? Weil es Next Step heißt. Da kann man einfach nicht leugnen, dass das einfach an Apple gebunden ist und du weißt, wie die Leute drauf sind.
Aber das heißt doch bei Mac Ruby immer noch NS String.
Das ist es doch. Da ändert sich doch gar nichts. Es ist nur eine andere Sprache, nicht ein Framework.
Wenn du schon Ruby machst, dann musst du keine neue Sprache lernen, um gleich loszulegen mit Nativ. Du musst nicht erst noch eine neue Sprache lernen und dann noch das Betriebssystem dazu. Das ist aber das, was du mit Objective-C machen musst. Du kannst gleich zwei Sachen auf einmal. Du musst anders denken und du musst noch was dazulegen.
Wenn die Methoden sowieso reingemapt werden aus dem echten Ruby noch mal zusätzlich in die Objekte, dann kannst du das bekannte Zeug weiter nutzen. Und du hast auch einen Haufen Probleme. Nicht, nehme ich mal an, also so irgendwie tropfendes Memory, was irgendwie so rausfällt und so was. Das ist so ein Problem.
Tropfendes Memory?
Das ist das Memory-Leak, das du vergisst, ein Objekt wieder frei zu geben.
Das habe ich schon seit Leopard im Objective-C.
Ja, aber ich habe auch iPhone zum Beispiel.
Genau, das ist der Punkt. Mac-Ruby auf dem iPhone gibt es halt deswegen noch nicht, weil auf dem iPhone halt keine Garbage Collection gibt.
Genau.
Und Ruby ist halt eine Garbage Collected Language. Ich hab sie schon gesagt. Ich hab auch gerade vor kurzem auf der Liste da einen Hacker gefunden, der irgendwie meint, ja das kann ja alles nicht so schwer sein. Die Adobe-Jungs haben ja auch ihr Flash irgendwie, was eigentlich garbage collected ist, aufs iPhone kompiliert gekriegt. Dann haben die eine garbage collection innerhalb von ihrem Programm.
Das kann ja sein.
Auf jeden Fall sind sie da gerade dabei. Und in dem Moment, wo sie das sozusagen hinkriegen, dass es auch ohne garbage collection support irgendwie läuft oder dass es auf der Plattform garbage collector gäbe, gibt es dann halt auch MacRobbie auf dem iPhone. Bloß das ist sozusagen der Knackpunkt, warum man noch kein Binary bauen kann, was eben auf dem iPhone einfach läuft.
Bei dem MacRobbie, als diese 05 in Aussicht gestellt wurde, das erste Mal, wurden ja auch schon ein paar Benchmarks mit veröffentlicht. Die wurden dann auch breit diskutiert. Und da gab es ja das erste Mal diesen Claim, das sei ja schnell, und dann gab es da viele Zweifel in der Robbie-Community nach dem Motto, ein Benchmark allein sagt jetzt erst mal noch gar nichts aus. Hat sich denn das jetzt mit dieser Beta-Version in irgendeiner Form, lässt sich das irgendwie festhalten?
Naja, also es ist so eigentlich, die haben halt, die Benchmarks haben suggeriert, dass es schneller wäre, als die Ruby 1.9. Standard-Implementierung sozusagen. So und es war halt offensichtlich Quatsch, weil viele Sachen waren langsamer. Nicht viel, aber waren so. Also Array Access zum Beispiel war zum Teil einfach langsamer. So und, aber die sind auf der Liste echt hoch aktiv. So und dann haben einfach diverse Leute geschrieben, ja hier irgendwie, ich hab hier so ein Projekt, hab ich einfach mal in Mac-Ruby geschmissen, war langsamer als in Ruby 1.9. Und dann hat der Laurent Sansonetti gleich gesagt, ja gib mal her den Code, wollen wir gleich mal sehen. Und jetzt sind sie halt zum Beta 1, haben sie schon echt ganz viele so einen Code genommen, den analysiert und daraufhin Optimierungen eingebaut, dass das halt auch wirklich schneller ist. Also wenn halt einer hinkommt und sagt, hier mein Projekt, ich benutze Array ganz viel und Array Access ist langsamer, dann sagt der, gib mal Code her, probier mal aus, macht irgendwie so eine Spec, um das zu testen und optimiert dann, also da scrollen auch am Tag 20 Commits durch, die sind da echt fett am Hacken. Also ich würde jetzt nicht behaupten, dass es wirklich schneller ist jetzt als das normale Ruby in allen Fällen, aber die sind auf jeden Fall gut dabei. Also ich denke, das kriegen sie bis zum final Release von der 05 auf jeden Fall hin. Was denkst du?
Ich hatte ja schon mal die Vermutung geäußert, dass diese Aktivität bedeuten könnte, dass Apple wirklich irgendwann so weit gehen würde, zu sagen, auf unserem Computer programmiert ihr entweder in Objective-C oder in Ruby.
Sie wollen das eine gleichberechtigte Sprache machen.
Gibt es da irgendeine Aussage oder ist das auch nur dein Gefühl?
Der Laurent suggeriert das auf jeden Fall die ganze Zeit. Also sie haben das Ziel, das genauso schnell zu kriegen oder nur minimal schneller als Objective-C-Variante.
Minimal schneller als Objective-C?
Minimal langsamer. Ich frage mich, ob das kompiliert.
Aber wenn am Ende auch mit LVM-Bytecode rauskommt, dann sollte es ja eigentlich langsamer sein, oder?
Genau, sie kriegen jetzt ja mit 05 diese Just-in-Time- und Ahead-of-Time-Compilation, was dann eben auch ermöglicht, so richtig Macho-Binaries zu machen. Und dann sollte das eben eh kein Problem sein.
Ich kann mir sehr gut vorstellen, dass das eigentlich auf gleicher Höhe liegt, also ich meine, das ist...
Achso, und sie können jetzt auch RBO-Files generieren, gegen die man dann wohl dynamisch auch linken kann aus Objective-C.
Das heißt, das sind auch die Object-Files mixbar. Und andersherum wahrscheinlich auch dann, oder?
Ich glaube ja, also das sowieso, ja.
Was heißt das so?
Na, du kannst halt...
Na, ich mach ein Framework und irgendwie Objective-C, schreib das, gebe dem dem Huckel das und der benutzt es dann in seinem Ruby.
Genau, und andersherum halt genauso, ich kann in Ruby ein Framework schreiben.
Plug-in schreiben für Photoshop oder was?
Weil das Object-Dings ja schon in macho Format ist.
Also Plug-in für irgendwas, was Objective-C basiert ist.
Und das ist natürlich richtig geil, dass man erstmal so ein Phototyping...
Genau, also sie wollen glaube ich einfach auch so die ganze Ruby-Community und das Momentum da einfach einsammeln. Die wollen die Leute da ins Boot ziehen und so.
Ja, vor allem, das sind ja auch alles Mac-Heads. Ich meine, Ruby ist auf Mac gestartet. Ich erinnere mich da noch an diesen Craze, mit Text-Mate und dem ganzen Screencast und so weiter. Die ganze Ruby-Community war 0,0x am Start mit Webseiten, die auch ordentlich designed waren. Also da steckt ja noch sehr viel mehr dahinter, als jetzt nur eine programmierte Sprache. Das war ja eher so eine Program-Design-Welle. Und diese Web-Affinität, die da mit reinkäme, also diese Ruby-Welt ist eine Web-Welt und das würde einfach eine ganze Menge Leute, Hirner, auf den Meck nativ tragen können, die eben in anderen Bereichen ihre eigenen Vorstellungen entwickelt haben.
Ja und was noch ganz bedeutend ist, ist halt, dass die Ruby-Community sehr auf Testen, Test-Driven-Development und so, und Behavior-Driven-Development. Und das ist ja so bei der Objective-C-Welt, also das geht schon mit Testen und so, aber es ist nicht so, dass in irgendwie den Apple-Tutorials irgendwie das jetzt irgendwie nahegelegt wird, schreib doch erstmal einen Test und dann implementiere und so weiter und so fort. Und das holen die sich jetzt auch gerade mit rein. Auf der Mailing-Liste von dem Mac-Ruby gibt's alle zwei Tage einen, der schreit irgendwie, ja, hier, ich will dieses Test-Framework benutzen, geht das schon? Und dann, ja, kannst du machen. So, das heißt, die ganzen Leute, die jetzt mit Test-Driven-Development da loslegen wollen, die können das halt mit so einem Cocoa-Apps auch machen. Punkt Nummer eins. Und dann gab's halt einen Typen, der hat das halt auch umgedreht, dass du deine Objective-C-Apps mit Ruby testen kannst. Mit Ruby testen kannst. Gibt's auch schon ein Recipe auf der Mac-Ruby-Seite, dass du halt mit Ruby-Test-Frameworks deine Mac OS X-App, also deine Objective-C-App unit testen kannst und so. Und das ist einfach auch total großartig. Also die holen sich halt auch so diese Testaffinität von der Ruby-Community mit rein, was eben auch so in der bisherigen Objective-C-Cocoa-Welt eigentlich noch nicht so da ist. Also jeder, der damit anfängt, kriegt nicht als erstes im Absatz gesagt, hier schreibt man ein Test so, was halt bei der Ruby-Community zum Beispiel so ist. Also ja, bei diesen Recipes, die veröffentlichen da jetzt auch regelmäßig irgendwie neue, bei macruby.org, da kriegt man bei Documentation, glaube ich, war das unten, gibt es zwei Recipes, Test Driven Development in Objective-C with Macruby vor ein paar Tagen, vor zwei Wochen rausgekommen, genau. Oder Create an Objective-C Bundle to Use with Macruby. Also die sind wirklich extrem heiß, einfach das an den Start zu kriegen.
Also ich kann nur hoffen, dass sie sich dann zumindest auch an einem bestimmten Punkt dazu durchringen können, zu sagen, jetzt ist das aber auch wirklich zukunftssicher. Weil wenn man natürlich erst mal jetzt anfängt, dafür zu entwickeln und dann wird das wieder weggesteept, so und...
Ach man kann das doch auch mal so sagen......CFS-ed.
Ich meine, so Ruby mal zu lernen, wollte ich, ich persönlich jetzt eh schon lange mal machen, aber das wird doch mal ein guter Aufhänger. Also ich hab schon hundertmal mit angefangen, aber nie tief genug reingekommen, um jetzt dauerhaft das Wissen aufzubauen. Und wenn das dann in Xcode funktioniert, Autocompletion und so ein Scheißdreck, auch alles schön, dann hat man gleich noch vernünftige Entwicklungsumgebung für das ganze Zeug und dann ist das doch alles schick.
Ich glaube auch, das könnte einen Riesen-Kick bringen, da würde ich auch schon nochmal nachfinden.
Du hast halt D-Trace und Instruments für deine Ruby-Ups auch, ne? Das ist halt auch... Und demnächst, also wenn die 05 rauskommen, sollten auch die meisten Ruby-Gems, das ist so was Ähnliches wie CPAN bei Perl, also wo die Ruby-Module noch zusätzlich installieren kannst, dann soll halt auch Rails auf Mac-Ruby laufen und der ganz andere Kram, der sonst im Ruby geht. Das heißt, du hast dann eine Multithreaded, eine echte Multithreaded mit Grand Central, kannst du deine Rails-Ups dann mal so richtig skalieren lassen, ja?
Das ist das mal sozusagen für Mac OS X Server.
Das wäre dann wirklich auch als Server-Applikation nicht ganz uninteressant, oder?
Ja, also das ist halt auch...
Da erzeugt man natürlich Code, der nur auf dem Mac läuft, oder?
Klar, aber das ist halt auch mal ein interessanter Gedanke, so Grand Central für eine Rails-Up dann zu benutzen.
Das stimmt. Wobei es ja auch durchaus sein kann, das ist ja Open Source, das ist auch auf anderen Plattformen, weil ich meine, man könnte ja die Lipdispatch auch nehmen und in das normale Ruby integrieren.
Die Jungs, also der Entwickler von Ruby, der verfolgt das auch sehr interessiert. Genau, die gucken da schon zu, was die Apple-Jungs in Anführungsstrichen oder die Mac-Ruby-Jungs da hacken, weil das jetzt eben von Apple finanziert ist und dadurch sind die da einfach ein bisschen mehr hinterher, als wenn Leute sagen, wir machen jetzt aus eigener Initiative mal JRuby oder so.
Das ist für die natürlich auch eine der offiziellen Sprachen für Mac-Development zu werden, wäre natürlich auch eine Adelung.
Aber die Sache ist halt auch, Objective-C ist ja, sagen sie auch, immer sehr Smalltalk inspiriert. Und das ist ja bei Ruby eben genauso. Ich glaube, da sind halt einfach so kulturell so... Die passen zusammen.
Definitiv. Das macht vorne und hinten Sinn. Und mich würde das extrem freuen, wenn sie mal aus dieser Single-Language-Geschichte ausbrechen. Und wenn es halt auch nur dann eine Second-Language ist.
Ist eigentlich Ruby so komplett, wie sagt man, objektorientiert?
Alles ist ein Objekt.
Auch Zahlen.
Alles.
Da gibt es keine Int sozusagen, so...
Alles ist ein Objekt. Das ist halt eine der wenigen Sprachen, wo wirklich alles ein Objekt ist. Alles.
Aber die Methoden zum Beispiel vom Framework, wenn ich sage, hier vorne im Array, gib mir mal den Count. Was kriegst du denn? Weil laut Framework krieg ich ja ein Int.
Na du kriegst, du kriegst in Ruby, in Mac Ruby kriegst du ein Objekt. Also ein Fix-Num-Objekt oder was auch immer.
Also ein Objekt, was eine Zahl ist.
Also alles in Ruby ist ein Objekt, auch immediate values.
Es gibt da nicht Int. Also es gibt da nicht Int im Sinne von...
Wie können die denn ihre Objekte tauschen und so weiter und so fort?
Indem sie halt die Core Foundation benutzen.
Also die haben halt, die haben da auch wirklich krasses Zeug gehackt, weil da erbt eben alles von Endless Object. Also das ist so gut.
Das ist ja nicht die Frage, sondern wenn das austauschbar sein soll mit Objective-C und ihr aber gar keine bei MacRuby keine Inns gibt, also wie soll denn das dann gehen?
C-Typen. Ich weiß nicht genau, wie es gelöst ist, aber bei Ruby kannst du schon immer C-Libraries benutzen. Also so ein C-Wrapper ist nichts Neues. Das muss nicht neu erfunden werden.
Naja, auf jeden Fall empfiehlt es sich da mal, genaues nachzulesen. Im Chat ist mein's glaube ich auch schon hinreichend mit MacRuby versorgt erstmal. Zumindest kriege ich hier schon Private Messages.
Dennis gib einfach nach, gib den Druck nach. Lern MacRuby, das ist... Ach, klar.
Wir machen jetzt einen Ruby Podcast.
Du kannst überhaupt keine von den modernen Sprachen.
Ich denke aber, dass es wirklich die Zukunft ist. Deswegen wollte ich das hier auch noch mal ausführlicher diskutiert haben. Das ist einfach mal Punkt. Und ich, ehrlich gesagt, fände MacDevelopment auch wieder interessanter. Weil für mich ist irgendwie Objective-C irgendwie zu all. Ich meine, jetzt gibt's halt auch Garbage Collection.
Und jetzt gibt's Blocks und Closures. Oder Attribute, oder Getter und Setter. Da musstest du ja bis Objective-C 2.0 auch immer von Hand dir da hinstricken. Wow, in Objective-C 2.0 kannst du dann mit nur einem Statement Getter und Setter dir generieren lassen.
Können wir jetzt weitermachen? Tja, was haben wir denn noch in unserer Wave? In unserer Wave wird auch noch irgendwie der Punkt Google Wave als Produktiv-Tool aufgerufen. Habt ihr denn so ein bisschen Erfahrungen gesammelt können? Ich muss sagen, ich find's ja noch sehr wie soll ich sagen, schwerfällig. Dieses Koi-Bars, auch wenn du sie liebst, ich find sie furchtbar, ich schneide immer noch nicht, wie groß meine Waves sind. Das ist einfach mal keine gute Erfindung. Es ist langsam, also auch so dieses ganze Scrollen und sich mal eben einen Überblick verschaffen, das gelingt mir irgendwie nicht. Was ich ganz besonders scheiße finde, ist, wenn man, ich hab jetzt hier diese Wave, ne, so.
Welche hast du denn jetzt gerade?
Public-Themen-Liste. So, da steht jetzt 84 neue Editierungen. Es gibt keine Möglichkeit jetzt zu sagen, okay, dann zeig mir doch jetzt mal diese 84 ab der letzten Änderungen, die er mir sozusagen...
Du kannst dann mit der Leertaste durchgehen.
Bitte?
Du kannst mit der Leertaste durchgehen.
Mit der Leertaste?
Genau so. Und dann? Und dann wählt er immer die Aktualisierung aus.
Ich, was? Ach, wie? Ich wähle hier die Wave aus. Und dann?
Na, wenn jetzt noch was Ungelesen da ist, warte mal, klick mal eine an. Das funktioniert noch nicht so perfekt, aber eine anklicken und dann kannst du mit der Nährtaste so durchgehen.
Man hätte mal das Handbuch lesen sollen, ja?
Aber diese Public Wave, die performt einfach mal so.
Ja, die ist total langsam, das ist wirklich unerträglich.
Okay, gut, ich hab da immer so, ich hab da immer die Vorwärts- und Rückwärts-Taste gesucht, aber auf Spaceband nicht bekommen. Geht auch Shift-Space?
Vor allem, das finde ich auch.
Weiß ich nicht, ob das schon geht.
Natürlich nicht.
Krass.
Die desediktiert meine Wave.
Die sind hier die ganze Zeit am JavaScript-Engine Performance rausholen, wie die Hölle, und hast du nicht gesehen, und posen WebKit und Firefox, und meine JavaScript-Engine ist schneller als deine und nochmal hundertprozentig schneller. Und dann hast du hier so eine Webseite, die eigentlich total unspektakulär aussieht und es ruckelt.
Also total unspektakulär ist das nicht. Außerdem ist da bestimmt auch eine Menge Optimierungspotenzial drin als in Valve.
Ich finde es trotzdem beeindruckend. Das ist eigentlich auch immer noch nicht so richtig.
Beeindruckend langsam oder beeindruckend?
Also es ist schon beeindruckend langsam, finde ich.
Ja gut, aber es ist ja noch nicht mal Beta. Also irgendwie mit Space, jetzt hat er aufgehört, mit Space das Richtige zu tun. Wann funktioniert denn das zuverlässig und wann nicht? Soll er erstmal wieder neu in diese Wave reingehen?
Also ich fange einfach immer oben an, klicke sozusagen das erste Item an und dann gehe ich mit der Leertaste durch.
Das erste Item, welches Item?
Ich klicke einfach einmal in die Wave rein, sodass die so mit diesem grünen Rahmen markiert ist. Und dann gehe ich mit der Leertaste durch die einzelnen Dinger.
Ja, aber ich hab dann zwischendurch was anderes gemacht und dann konnte ich nicht weiterspacen. Also es ist auf jeden Fall alles noch irgendwie so ein bisschen...
Das ist noch ein bisschen buggy alles.
Das ist so ein bisschen komisch.
Wobei, ich meine, diese Public-Themenliste, die wir haben, das dürfte eine der sehr, sehr großen Waves sein.
Aber ich hab's ja schon getwittert und ich hab's glaub ich auch schon tausendmal erzählt, aber was mir wirklich ernsthaft wieder fehlt, ist einfach, ich verstehe nicht, warum es hier keine Outliner-Funktion gibt. Warum kann ich hier solche verschachtelten Sachen, warum ist da nicht da vorne einfach so ein kleines Dreieck und ich klappe das zusammen?
Das verstehe ich nicht.
Und vor allem, ich will Haken haben.
Das wär doch mal so ein schöner Bot, mit dem man das machen könnte.
Ach, ich glaub, das gehört hier einfach mal rein in dieses User-Interface. Das ist eher eine User-Interface-Frage, wie man mit so einer Outline umgeht.
Also ich bin mal sehr gespannt, wie das weitergeht. Also bei kleineren Waves finde ich, dass die Geschwindigkeit absolut in Ordnung ist und auch die Übersichtlichkeit. Ich hab jetzt so ein Paar, die ich mit anderen zusammenführe. Das funktioniert alles soweit ganz gut. Und unauffällig. Wovor ich echt noch... Ich glaube, es wird viele Leute einfach massiv überfordern.
Ich hab mein Telefon gerade mal kurz eingeschaltet, weil ich eine SMS mal schicken muss.
Man soll es nicht mit Skype machen.
Ich glaube, das wird viele Leute erst mal überfordern. Und dann auch so Privacy-Funktionen, wenn man jemanden einlädt, dass der dann plötzlich die gesamte Wave sehen kann und so was.
Das ist für Surfer vielleicht interessant.
Aber ich meine, diese Public-Themen-Liste hier, die sich jetzt hier von den Hörern zusammengestellt hat. Ich weiß jetzt nicht genau, 107 Leute sind da jetzt dabei. Das hat ganz gut funktioniert. Also dafür, dass diese Bullet-Point-Editiergeschichte relativ mager ist.
Ja, die ist wirklich auch sehr mager.
Das ist nicht besonders gut, aber dafür ist das Ergebnis hervorragend. Damit kann man jetzt wirklich was anfangen. Im Prinzip fände ich es ganz spannend, ob man auch eine Timeline damit hinbekommen würde. Dafür fehlt mir noch so ein bisschen der explizite Support für Tabellenartiges. Sowas fände ich noch ganz gut.
Also ich kann am Augenblick keinen tun, mit dem man sowas besser hinkriegen würde.
Tabellen?
Nicht Tabellen, aber eine gemeinsam geführte Liste, an der mehrere Leute arbeiten. Na ja, aber Wiki sind ja die Hölle in der Bedienung.
Vor allen Dingen, da hast du immer das Problem, wer zuerst speichert und so weiter. Du hast jetzt nicht so, dass du gleichzeitig an einem Artikel schreiben könntest, ohne Probleme. So das ist schon... So ein Sub-Ether-Edit hat halt auch nicht jeder. Und dann gibt es halt noch diese... Es gibt ja eine ganze Menge so kollaborative Schreibtools, also Google Docs und was weiß ich nicht, wie sie alle heißen. Da geht es schon auch, aber ich glaube, da ist dann halt auch so dieses Benutzermanagement und Buddy-List und so.
Ja, das ist alles sehr schön. Ich mag das ja auch. Aber ich... Also bei mir steht jetzt sozusagen diese Themenliste für die Sendung in Konkurrenz zu dem, was ich mit Omni Outliner mache. Und bei Omni Outliner habe ich so 2, 3, 4 Features. Die sind für mich wirklich der große Unterschied. Der erste Punkt ist, ich kann einfach sagen, jeder Bullet Point hat was zum Abhaken. Das heißt, ich habe so meine Outline und wenn ich dann die erstellt habe, kann ich die dann einfach durchgehen und kann sie einfach abhaken. Das ist schon mal super. Auch so mit so einer, in die Outline, also in die Verschachtelung nach unten weitergehenden, so habe ich alle da unten abgehakt, dann ist der gesamte Bereich abgehakt. Das ist schon mal etwas, was mir hier fehlt. Dann überhaupt Outlining. Also das ist, klar, du hast zwar hier Bullet Points, aber man sieht ja, wie man da drin rumeditieren kann. Es ist nicht so, dass an der Stelle wirklich eine Outline vorgehalten wird sein. Du hast jetzt hier Text, der formatiert ist, wie eingerückte Bullet Points, aber das ist was vollkommen anderes als eine richtige Outline. Eine Outline weiß immer, wie viele Kinder sie hat und so weiter, in welcher Hierarchie das zueinander steht.
Ja, das ist kein Ausliner.
Das haben wir jetzt verstanden. Ja, das ist wirklich der Punkt. Ich bekniehe ja hier auch schon immer Martin und Dom mit ihrem Sub-Ether-Edit, dass sie doch mal irgendwie das mit Omni-Outliner verheiratet oder sowas einbauen. Klar sagen sie natürlich, das ist aber ein Editor. Das sehe ich ja vollkommen ein. Aber diese Fähigkeit, kollaborativ zu sein mit einem Outliner, das gehört einfach mal verheiratet. Weil dann kriegst du solche inhaltsschweren Konzepte einfach schneller gemacht.
Also Sub-Ether-Edit ist dafür auch das falsche Tool. Das muss ins Web, das muss im Browser laufen. Das muss ins Internet. Im Browser.
Das muss.
Gut, meinetwegen auch im Browser. Wave ist ein Browser, trotzdem hat es keine Outlines. Das ist natürlich das, was mich stört. Ich hätte halt einfach gerne Outlines. Was habe ich noch bei Omni-Outliner, was auch sehr cool ist, ist, wie sie mit URLs umgehen und mit Bildern. Wenn du bei Omni-Outliner in deine Outline irgendwas reindrackst oder eine URL reindrackst, dann wird die zu einem eigenen Objekt. Das heißt, du hast diese URL und die erscheint dann sozusagen gleich als so klickbarer Button und kannst die aber auch nochmal aufklappen und dann kriegst du sozusagen die volle URL. Sehr schön damit umzugehen. Die URLs gehen irgendwie nicht kaputt und so. Die kannst du ja nicht so kaputt formatieren. Und mit Bildern ist es ähnlich. Du kannst also die Bilder dann einfach auch einklappen und dann tauchen sie halt nicht auf. Hier bläst du die Wave halt auch gleich enorm damit auf. Also dieses ganze Information Hiding, was beim Outlining mit drinsteckt, das ist halt hier nicht drin. Aber gerade wenn du eben mit 108 Leuten an so einem Informationskonvolut arbeitest, willst du einfach die Möglichkeit haben, selektiv bestimmte Dinge auch auszublenden. Alleine, um schon mal einen Überblick zu bekommen. Du kannst sagen, ich will jetzt nur Level 1 sehen, ich will jetzt nur Level 2 sehen. Und was natürlich bei Omni-Outliner nochmal speziell schick ist, jetzt halt ich auch gleich das Maul. Ich muss mal die Lanze berechnen. Du durftest jetzt über Ruby.
Du hattest doch diese Jingle-Musik, die auch bei Verkaufsshows im Hintergrund jingelt.
Spalten. Ich kann halt in so einer Outline auch Spalten machen. Ich kann dann irgendwie jeder Outline einfach nochmal Metaelemente hinzufügen.
Und er kam. Und spaltete.
Und spaltete, rannte das Schwert in die Outline.
Das geht doch alles schon, oder? Du brauchst doch nur Tab drücken. Dein Outline ist irgendwie... Bei SubEasterEdit nicht.
SubEasterEdit ist ein Text-Editor, das ist kein Outliner.
Omni-Outliner ist dein Produkt der Firma Omni. Ja, mit Tab und kein Kostengünstig.
Da kannst du einerzeit einen Tab hinzufügen. Aber das ist was anderes, als ob du eine komplette Hierarchie verschiebst.
Haben wir denn hier vielleicht noch...
Vergiss es einfach.
Bei uns gibt es ja auch noch. Wir müssen ja aber dann die Konkurrenzprodukte erwähnen.
Die Welt braucht ein Outliner.
Um jetzt das Thema mal radikal zu wechseln, wollen wir nicht über Outliner reden. Habt ihr dieses tolle Video gesehen von der Eröffnung des Microsoft Stores des ersten?
Furchtbar.
Hab ich gestern gesehen oder vorgestern, weiß ich auch nicht warum, wahrscheinlich weil es bei unserem Mac-Blog war.
Dort grob hat es Creepy genannt, das fand ich wirklich sehr treffend.
Sag mal, dieses ganze Gekreische im Hintergrund, weil wenn man das so hinguckt, da sind gar keine Leute, die kreischen, haben die das da drauf gelegt?
Das ist wie im Apple Store, das war doch auch, wenn man ein iPhone kaufte, da hatte doch alle geklappt und geklappt.
Ja, schon, aber da kreischt keiner rum. Ich glaube, diese Gekreische haben die oben drauf gelegt. Das ist gefaked.
Das Gekreische ist ein Feature von Windows 7.
Das Video noch mal rausbringen, wo man so hört...
Don't scream, we scream for you.
Als ob die Leute ganz bisschen klatschen.
Jedes Mal, wenn eine Aktion geklappt hat, ein Klick funktioniert, geht es dann so...
Und alle so...
Creepy ist wirklich die beste Bezeichnung. Ich dachte auch wirklich nur, wie schlecht seid ihr eigentlich?
Und wie viele Läden haben Sie jetzt schon einen?
Ja, das glaube ich war jetzt der erste Microsoft Store. Und er ist halt genauso aufgebaut wie in Apple Stores.
Er sieht wirklich eins zu eins so aus.
Ja, aber dann stehen da diese ganz hässlichen, ekligen Windows Laptops da rum.
Und von welchen Firmen sind die dann? Hewlett-Packard. Der John Gruber der letzten Artikel, eigentlich geht mir der Typ ja ein bisschen auf den Sack manchmal. Ich glaube, das geht ihm so. Aber sein letzter Artikel fand ich ganz gut, dieses Herden-Syndrom. Was hat er genau geschrieben? Wie heißt seine Webpage? Daring Firewall, Schnick schnack..net und Daring Firewall. Hier, Hurt Mentality. Ist ein ziemlich langer Artikel, aber den sollte man sich mal durchlesen. Ich finde, da ist einiges dran. Jetzt sind die Leute voll so nervös. Was ist denn da nun dran? Er legt sich noch nicht durch, Mann. Was schreibt er eigentlich? Nein, ist zu viel. Ich will auch schon gehen.
Hurt Mentality.
Das haben sie früher gesagt. Apple baut halt OS und Rechner. Alle haben früher mal gesagt, dass der Laden sowieso pleite geht. Das sagen sie anzwischen nicht mehr. Dieses Phänomen ist wirklich verschwunden. Aber dass sie früher auch schon mal gesagt haben, die sollen ihr OS lizenzieren und Hardware sollen sie einstellen. Die anderen haben gesagt, die sollen ordentliche Hardware bauen und dann aber auch Windows drauf machen. Sie sollen sich an den PC-Markt anpassen. Da schreibt es, dass es voll blöd ist. Das ist genau das Gute an Apple, dass sie beides machen. Und die ganzen PC-Hersteller so. Dell stellt halt PCs her, aber sie müssen ein Windows drauf machen. Sie haben eigentlich gar nichts anderes, was sie da drauf machen können. Sie können sich gar nicht abgrenzen von dem Joe-Schrauber-Ladener, der auch irgendwie PCs baut. Und eventuell sogar wirklich besser. Weil die Motherboards sind auch alle Standard-Hardware von Intel oder von sonst wo. Sie schrauben halt als Zeug nur zusammen. Und was macht Dell eigentlich? Die machen da ein anderes Gehäuse drum oder so. Aber sonst großartig viel machen die ja nicht. Okay, vielleicht macht Dell eigene Motherboards. Ich weiß nicht so genau.
Auf jeden Fall machen die kein richtiges Engineering.
Ich glaube, die geben sich da schon auch Mühe. Aber die können sich nicht so wirklich vom Rest des Marktes abgrenzen. Weil am Ende, was machst du drauf? Machst halt ein Windows drauf. Okay, man kann der jetzt auch noch für andere Sachen einsetzen. So ist es nicht. Aber trotzdem am Ende ist es irgendwie PC-Laden, die da so eine Hardware machen und sich nicht wirklich abgrenzen können. Und Windows kann sich aber auch nicht richtig absetzen, weil die haben halt keine eigene Hardware. Also die müssen halt immer das bauen für die ganzen Hardware-Schrauber, die halt da die Hardware bauen. Und den Vorteil hat halt Apple. Die haben halt Hardware und Software und haben halt dieses Problem nicht und können sich deswegen auch prima absetzen.
Aber was hat das jetzt mit der Herden-Mentalität zu tun?
Na, dass die früher mal gesagt haben, Apple soll doch das machen, was alle anderen auch machen, nämlich den PC-Schrauber weggehen oder den Windows-Weg gehen und ihr OS lizenzieren und das mit der Hardware sein lassen.
Jetzt wird hier wieder Schoki. Ich weiß nicht, ob das mit Schoki so eine gute Idee ist.
Wir sollten lieber Chips essen.
Deine Idee war mal einen Frühstück zu machen während wir eine Sendung machen.
Genau, Eier aufhaken und so.
Was ist los übrigens da? Schmeckenbrot.
Schoki wieder da.
Habt ihr das mitbekommen, dass auf der IMAC-Seite, auf der neuen, da sind ja auch Videos drin, die sind jetzt mit HTML5 da eingebaut?
Zumindest, wenn du mit dem Safari da hinkommst.
Zumindest, wenn man mit dem Safari hinkommt. Ich bin nicht mit einem anderen, mit Firefox auch.
Gerrit hat das irgendwie auch entdeckt und andere Browser, andere Ergebnisse. Also sie machen das sozusagen...
Ach, sie kompatibel ist noch ein bisschen. Das ist doch nett.
Naja, es ist ja auch bestimmt nur Flash. Sie werden halt ihre Videos nicht mit Okta raufstellen. Das heißt, die Leute, die kein...
Ach, Firefox dürfte das dann eigentlich nicht können.
Die Leute, die kein H264 mit ihrem OS mitgeliefert bekommen, sollten da das nachsehen haben. Dann machen sie wahrscheinlich wieder Fallback auf Flash.
Na, auf QuickTime.
Nee, sie machen kein Fallback auf Flash. Apple hat Flash seit einiger Zeit auf ihrer Webseite komplett...
Hatten die jemals Flash drauf?
Sie machen dann QuickTime als Fallback. Also entweder hast du QuickTime installiert oder du hast einen HTML5-Browser der H264 kann oder du siehst keine Videos.
Mein gelder Meckentasch.
Das ist schon echt hardcore, oder?
Wenn sie Click-to-Flashes von Apple finanziert?
Tja, Click-to-Flash ist auf jeden Fall eine Erfolgsgeschichte. Ich hoffe, dass sie da aber noch weiter dran weitermachen. Das ist sehr hilfreich. Also das hat die CPU-Last auf meinem Rechner doch erheblich gesenkt. Das hat dem an diesem ganzen Flash-Scheiß einfach nicht mehr laufen lassen.
Ja, das wären diese ganzen schicken HTML5-Video-Applikationen und JavaScript und Canvas, wird das bestimmt alles wieder rausholen.
Das kann allerdings auch sein.
Darum war es eine gute Entscheidung, sich gleich den Cut-Core...
Jetzt brauch ich noch einen Click-to-JavaScript und einen Click-to-Your-CPU-Hog-Insertier. So, sind wir denn jetzt durch? Wir haben jetzt irgendwie drei Stunden. Ist doch eigentlich ganz gut, oder? Wir wollten ja nicht mehr so lange machen.
Ja, ich müsste auch jetzt so langsam mal...
Ich müsste auch mal so langsam so mal.
Sind alle Themen schon durch jetzt?
Ja, soll ich jetzt etwa noch mal über Nokia herziehen?
Nein, please don't! Spare the children.
Wir müssen auf jeden Fall erwähnen, dass sie ja jetzt Apple verklagt haben.
Ja, das ist lustig, das ist eigentlich...
Ja, sagen sie nicht so ganz genau, sondern wegen Technologien, die mit UNTS und WLAN und so weiter zu tun haben, wie ein Telefon mit dem Netz spricht. Und angeblich gibt es wohl andere Hersteller, die da bereit waren, ihnen da Lizenzgebühren zu zahlen, dafür den Scheiß.
Na, wenn man mal richtig hinterher gelesen hat, dann war es so, dass Qualcomm eigentlich immer Nokia verklagt hat, wegen genau den gleichen Gründen. Also, dass Nokia Patente von Qualcomm benutzt. Und die haben sich dann so ein bisschen rumgeschritten und haben sich dann geeinigt, okay, Nokia rückt ein paar eigene Patente für Qualcomm raus, und deswegen gibt Qualcomm dann die Patente für Nokia. Und da hat Nokia schon gelernt, so geht es. Und deswegen haben sie sich gedacht, mit Patenten kann man noch ein bisschen Geld verdienen und machen das gleiche jetzt mit Apple. Wahrscheinlich würde es sogar noch so enden, weil Apple hat aber auch einige Patente, die die Nokia gebrauchen. Ich kann mir nicht vorstellen, dass Apple da nicht auch was in der Tasche hat.
Ich frage mich, was Patente sein sollen, wie man mit UMTS umgeht. Ist das nicht irgendwie, wie man so ein Telefon baut? Irgendeiner muss den Scheiß ja unten erfinden. Ja, aber dann sind die Patente im Standard mit drin.
Das heißt aber auch nicht, dass sie frei sind dann.
Nein, aber dann zahlt man das mit seinen Lizenzgebühren, damit man dann eben so ein UMTS-Phone baut.
Die Menschen haben auch was gefunden, was Apple offentlicht.
Wahrscheinlich ist der Airplane-Motor bei Nokia zuerst gewesen.
Sie sagen ja gar nicht, was wir machen.
Wie man nicht mit dem Netz umgeht.
Was soll denn das für eine Erfindung sein? Ich meine, was soll denn da so innovativ sein?
Da sind sie bisher auch noch nicht so richtig mit rausgerückt, oder?
Ja, und mit WLAN, ich bitte dich, man hat es mal gesehen, wie so ein Nokia-Telefon mit WLAN umgeht, da kriegst du doch das Kotzen.
Vielleicht ist das einfach, wie sie einen Chip draufkriegen, dass sie gleichzeitig auf zwei UMTS und WLAN senden können, ohne dass sie sich gegenseitig zu sehr in die Quere kommen, weißt du was? Das muss doch nicht das User-Enterface sein.
Vielleicht hat Nokia rausgefunden, dass man die Antenne hinter Plastik tun muss und dass sie da besser funken kann.
Statt hinter dem Alu-Gehäuse.
Das gibt ja heutzutage wirklich Patente auf alles, ne?
Aber wenn sie sich das auch patentieren lassen, dass das Ding runterfällt und sofort ist das Glas kaputt.
Oder dass es diesen Silent-Button an der Seite gibt oder so.
Den hat Nokia nun ausgerechnet nicht.
Vielleicht haben sie trotzdem Patent drauf.
Nicht, dass sie ihre eigenen Patente anwenden würden. Wir werden nur verklagen. Gut, schwer zu sagen.
Aber einen Punkt hätte ich doch noch.
Das geht jetzt hier noch eine Weile.
Ja, der ist wirklich relativ wichtig. Der steht auch ganz oben in der Themenliste. Und zwar Zensursula Tod? Ich sollte mal schon ganz kurz drauf eingehen.
Ja, der erste, der Wikimedia ist gelöscht, wegen der Relevanz.
Da muss man ein Mikrofon wieder ein bisschen mehr zusammenbuchen.
Nicht mehr so viel durch die Nase.
Okay, weiter, weiter. Jetzt ist doch eine Konditionsverhandlung, zumindest ausgesetzt für ein Jahr. Wohl gerüchteweise nur damit die CDU das Gesicht warmen kann und ihr ein niegelnagelneues Gesetz für das sie so hart gekämpft haben, nicht so total weg ist. Sieht so aus, als ob das Zugangserschwernes Gesetz weg vom Festerteil ist.
Damit kann man als Partei irgendwie eh kein Geld verdienen, weil es keine Lobbygruppe gibt, die Geld zahlen würde, die das da sperren und filtern. Was bei dem Atomausstieg schon wieder was ganz anderes ist. Da hat die FDP gesagt, ganz so einfach ist der Atomausstieg, aber nicht mit uns, das heißt, es gibt mehr Geld von der Atomindustrie. Das geht bei Vorratsdatenspeicherung und Kinderpornosperren nicht. Da kommt keiner und sagt, ihr habt voll viel Geld, ihr solltet es mal sperren, da kam keiner. Da haben wir uns gedacht, das ist auch nicht so wichtig. Dann können wir der FDP auch sagen, habt ihr. Dann halten die wenigstens ihre Klappe und sind ruhig.
Dann ist erklärt die Welt.
Können wir festhalten, dass das weg ist? Sie haben es vorher aus irgendwelchen Gründen eingeführt.
Ich glaube, es ist erst, wenn die Provider sagen, wir machen jetzt wirklich nicht scharf die Kisten.
Es ist schon verschoben, aber es ist auch kein... Also ich würde nicht behaupten, dass es ein Gewinn, oder so heißt es, ein Verdienst der FDP ist, sondern ich glaube schon, dass es dieser ganzen Medienrummel, der da vorher stattgefunden hat...
Das ist definitiv ein Verdienst der Community. So sieht es aus. Hätte es diesen Widerstand nicht gegeben, hätten die sich jetzt in Koalitionsverhandlungen scheiß drum gekümmert, dann würden sie das einfach nicht machen.
Ich weiß nicht, ob sie sich drum gekümmert hätten oder nicht, aber sie haben sich drum gekümmert. Das haben andere Parteien vorher nicht gemacht. Für wen auch immer das ist.
Und der Westerwelle, ich kann ihn ja persönlich...
Westerwave heißt er.
Westerwave, Schwesterwelle. Ich kann ihn ja eigentlich nicht so leihen, ist ja nicht so, also wahrscheinlich gar kein Politiker. Aber ich glaube, doof ist er nicht, weil ich glaube, der hat sich jetzt durch diesen Stunt schon noch mal irgendwie eins, zwei Prozent geholt. Könnte ich mir gut vorstellen.
Nach den Wahlen bringt das überhaupt nichts.
Durch diesen Vorratsdatenspeicherungsplan.
Vorratsdatenspeicherung ist nach wie vor im Betrieb.
Da hat sich nichts geändert.
Ja, was? Sie haben einen Gesetz, was sowieso keiner haben wollte, was überhaupt nicht durchsetzbar ist.
Ja, aber ich hab das ja getwittert, als der Spiegelartikel kam. Und ich muss den wahrscheinlich jetzt eine Minute gelesen haben, nachdem der gerade auf der Homepage da bei Spiegel erschien, hab das getwittert, ich hatte irgendwie 30, 40 Retweets. Und da haben schon manche geschrieben, naja, dann war meine Stimme für die FDP doch nicht so schlecht. Oder irgendwie, naja, so schlecht ist die FDP ja dann doch nicht. Oder dann doch besser, als ich dachte.
Also, ich...
Die FDP ist ja auch hauptsächlich meine Wellenlänge. Aber ich glaube, die haben sich dadurch schon ein paar Stimmen rübergezogen. So läuft halt.
Wenn sie das nicht getan hätten, hätten sie sich so ins Knie geschossen, dass sie geradezu gezwungen wären.
Ach, eigentlich war das Thema doch durch.
Nee, das Thema war nicht durch. Weil alle haben natürlich jetzt mit Agus-Augen dahingeschaut, was machen sie. Dann wären sie jetzt gleich von Anfang an schon da eingebrochen und hätten noch nicht mal das gebracht. So einen dahinladen, bis sie selbst einzuführen, was keiner haben wollte.
Also ich meine, die SPD wollte es haben, die CDU wollte es haben. Von so viel zum Thema wollte niemand haben. Es gibt jetzt einen tierischen Aufschrei von einer Unicef unter anderem. Oh Gott, oh Gott, die haben das Internet nicht gesperrt.
Diese Regierung ist noch überhaupt nicht gebildet. Sie hat noch gar nichts getan. Ich lehne jetzt wirklich ab, irgendwelche halbseidenen Ankündigungen, die jetzt noch nicht mal unterschrieben sind, irgendwie zu kommentieren.
Moment mal, das Gesetz wäre jetzt wahrscheinlich schon eine Aktion.
Das Gesetz hat auch diverse Probleme gehabt vor Gerichten und es ist irgendwie dem BKA schon verboten worden, irgendwelche Sperrlisten zu machen, vollkommen unabhängig von diesen Koalitionsgesprächen. Das jetzt sozusagen als Ergebnis der Koalitionsverhandlungen da hinzustellen, halte ich für etwas gewagt. Ja, es gab diese gerichtliche Auseinandersetzung und diese Sperrlisten dürfen noch gar nicht erstellt werden. BKA musste sogar eine...
Ja, auf Vertragsbasis nicht. Aber auf Gesetzbasis natürlich schon.
Das klären wir dann in den Kommentaren zur Sendung.
Ja, komm, jetzt haben wir drei Stunden über Mengen-Schulhausch geredet, jetzt machen wir nicht dieses Politik-Fass noch auf. Jetzt ist irgendwie Schluss.
Aber...
So, jetzt gucken wir mal, ob überhaupt irgendwas... Also wenn ich den Chat richtig mitverfolgt habe, ist da jetzt so Kapitelunterstützungstechnisch nicht viel gekommen. Jetzt können wir noch mal gucken.
Im Thema haben sie da irgendeinen Marker hingesetzt.
Okay, dann bin ich mal gespannt. Vielleicht landet das in der Wave zu dieser Sendung, dieser Public Wave.
Da doch hier, Nummer, Zeichen, Chapter.
Okay. Und sollte sich da sozusagen irgendeine, relativ zum Nullpunkt-Liste finden, dann werde ich die verwenden als Kapitel Futter. Und dann schauen wir mal, was dabei rauskommt. Und ob da überhaupt irgendwer was mit anfangen kann, finde ich ja mal ganz spannend. So, und jetzt? Haben wir es, oder? Max, bist du zufrieden?
Fette, wer ist es weg?
Genau. Da machen wir jetzt nur noch in jeder Sendung so eine Trauerminute.
Ey, Fiebern schon Half-SX entgegen.
Okay, vielen Dank für dein Dabeisein. Und ja, wir alle hören uns irgendwann wieder und mal gucken, ob wir wieder einen Samstag senden oder nicht. Wir machen jetzt Schluss und bis bald.